What was that sound?
What was that?
That was weird.
Anyway.
Oh, the menu.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Hold on.
Oh, would it be under?
Oh, pause!
I didn't know you were in here.
Hold on a second.
Oh, welcome to Minecraft!
Give me one second.
Am I late?
No, I just started.
Oh my god.
I looked down and she's like, she was sitting.
my cats i didn't know my cat was in here she was like
sitting and she was like meowing at me and then i just
looked down and she like she was just laying dead on the
floor oh she's banana no she's stretching yeah you have
anything you want to say pass you want to say anything no
you're so cute okay let me let her out real quick save her
pitiful life she's just a babe maybe she wants to stay I
can't tell.
Do you want to stay in here?
I can't tell what you want.
I won't be able to let you out later, probably.
Stop looking at me.
What do you want?
Oh my goodness.
She's a stretchy girl.
Knox, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
And Mike Dyson, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, uh, no.
I think I'll just let her out.
Sorry, I didn't realize she was in here.
Okay, give me one second.
Okay, we're good.
Okay.
Dodging Mike Tyson's legal name once more, Mint.
Thank you eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Railarm!
Quick one.
Happy birthday to you.
Dear Railarm.
Woo!
Oh my god.
Sniper Monkey.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
An 8-bit romance.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Why is everybody gifting?
What was going on?
Okay, I have to figure out how to turn this down.
Maybe just the master volume.
But, oh, that's much better.
Weird logarithm, thanks for the tango tip.
Let me turn it up just a little bit more.
Like 75?
Okay, this is better.
For Fox's sake.
Thank you both.
Thank you for the five.
Thank you for the ten.
Spang!
Um, what was I saying?
Oh, I have to tell Henya that I'm ready, I think.
I'm not ready, though.
Oh gosh, you guys, I'm so nervous.
Is she already on?
Oh, oh, Henya dao.
Oh my gosh.
You guys!
This is my first time ever playing in the V-show.
Minecraft server.
If you're unaware, they kind of recently, somewhat recently
opened it up to other indie VTubers.
And so I asked if I could join and check it out.
But there's all sorts of balls.
Balls.
There's all sorts of mods that I don't know.
I don't know at all what they're like.
yeah um later on um iron mouse might join us as well um she
said maybe in like an hour so we shall see
okay i'm gonna i'm just gonna i'm just gonna join
oh look at who is that that's really the server is much
different than i am at oh oh oh oh langie oh oh oh whoa Oh,
look, you can see me in the corner!
Why am I on a building?
Where am I?
Why am I up here?
Um, your PC is dead.
Nox, I give it the 50 gifted!
Hey there, ghost lady, have a stream!
Thanks!
Thank you!
Wow!
Oh wow!
Wait, this is Crouch.
Wait, why is seat?
Pink concrete brick stairs.
Wait, oh, I'm laying down!
What?
There's like a lay down button.
Hello.
Dial.
Oh, thanks for the five-gifted.
Bye, Roblox.
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
I wonder if she is if she's conscious.
I wonder if she doesn't know that I'm on.
Wait, what is all this stuff that I have?
Whoa!
One of 97?
What is this?
I have an uncommon hat grab.
Wait, no, hat grab bag.
I have an info guide.
I have a hamburger.
Oh, yeah.
I have a candle holder.
Iron staff of building.
A decorative gift.
A warped mailbox.
And a style magazine.
Um...
What are those arrows to...
So curious.
Yay, join us, Dayo!
I'm in... I'm ready!
Hanya!
I'm in Minecraft.
Oh!
I'm on top of a building.
Hanya, help me!
Why is there another Hanya over there?
She found one of the pictures.
What do the pictures do?
Oh wait, this says V.
Shoujo cat ears.
Can I wear it?
On my hat?
No.
It's just a magazine of...
Wait, right click to unlock cosmetic.
Oh.
Hello!
Oh, someone else joined.
Someone else joined.
I did try right clicking it.
This is me right clicking it.
I'm on a building.
I think there's in-game voice chat, but just in case...
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
What is that?
Oh my god, there's a creature down there.
Okay, it's actually maybe better that I'm up here because it
might kill me.
Oh, and my hand!
Hello?
They disappeared.
Wait.
Is that Henya?
Minto?
Henya!
Can you hear me?
She's not in
here.
Minto?
Henya!
What is...
I'm right here!
Wait, how do I...
Oh, there she is!
Hello!
You don't know about the voice chat.
Hold on.
Oh, I'm on push to talk.
Hello?
Oh, hello!
Wait, I hear your voice from your side, though.
Oh, wait.
I think I have to change my microphone.
Okay, that should be good.
Nice!
Oh, you look so cute!
You're so small!
Oh, you can change your heights in here.
You want to change it?
Okay.
How do I change?
This way, this way.
to run oh now i know okay okay what the this way this way
she's a mermaid oh my god yeah i have a bird i can give you
a necklace to turn into the mermaid what there you go okay
this is a regular size and you can be a small or bigger
there you go you're bigger now come here Come here, Henya.
I'm gonna squish you.
Come here, Henya.
Like the bug you are.
Wait, is this...
Oh, look at you!
You're the same size as me now!
It's the same!
Oh, we're so small!
Yeah, it is!
Isn't this... How do you jump high?
Wait, is this...
You're just short?
Yeah, you're shorter now.
is the smallest color i think you're like one block in a
little bit i'm tiny you are you are wow oh hi adi hello i
didn't know you guys were over here hi hi we're streaming
and uh this is the first time me coming to the server yeah
yeah welcome in hello i was just admiring the uh the art on
your house over here oh my god what the heck that's my house
by the way You see the purple house over there?
That's not Michi's house?
Yeah, yeah, it's not.
It was my house and people putting on paintings on it.
And now it's...
People cannot see the magnificent house that I built.
Yeah, who would do that?
Who would put a painting on your house?
Yeah.
It's so messed up.
Wasn't it you?
I don't know what you're talking about.
See, those aren't mine.
Those, I didn't do those.
Would you like to see the house?
Yeah, give me one second because I'd have to change my keys.
Yeah, of course, of course.
Sprint, sneak, sprint.
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm good.
Yes.
I'm good.
Oh, welcome.
This is my house, my beautiful house.
It's covered now, but it is my beautiful house.
Whoa.
Ooh.
It's, uh, it's really...
um beautiful what why why you're why you're like that you're
you're not self-impressed who is that okay that's that's
mochi and uh maybe that's katie is that mochi also mochi
build the house for me would you like to Take a look inside
of.
Yeah!
It's right here.
Enjoy that.
Whoa, whoa.
What's that sound?
Right here.
Yeah, it's inside here.
It's inside here.
In here.
Oh, oh, I won't die.
I don't know what place is this.
I don't know what place is this, but it's something.
What is that sound?
You have like a wild animal in here.
Ow!
You good?
Okay, let me take you back to there.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, my God.
You can grab people.
You can, she's got, oh, my God, she's got me on a leash.
Oh, my God.
You press shift and then right click and you can hold
people, but it has to be empty hand.
Shift, right click.
It's not working.
Oh, really?
Do you have anything on your hand?
No.
Hmm.
Oh, she meant sneak.
Oh.
Oh, my sneak's not working though.
I don't know why.
Oh.
Let me try this.
Oh, yeah.
It has my sneak and touch.
Oh.
I like that.
Why is my sneak not working?
Oh.
I think the original key should be a shift.
Yeah, but I changed it.
It's okay.
Oh, you changed it.
Yeah, you can try it later.
Yeah.
Wow, that was so much fun.
Also, we have a thing that is called Waystone, so if you
touch it, you can keep it here anytime you want.
Oh, Henya Land.
Yeah, make sure you touch it every time when you see these.
I'm gonna always be here.
Henya Land.
Why are you licking, Naya?
Because it's actually delicious.
It's Yeah, but it says Henya land on it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, of course, of course.
I'm gonna do a summoning circle here.
Oh, Henya, Henya, Henya.
Oh no, oh no.
What did I just get into?
Nothing, nothing, nothing.
It's all good.
Please don't bother these a lot of signs.
Zen faced it.
Ready for a fun...
Oh.
Well, actually, you can't get inside because Ari gave me
this magnificent sign.
We can get in from here, I guess.
Okay.
Oh, whoa!
Whoa.
Here it goes.
Ta-da-da!
Whoa!
Welcome in!
Oh, what was that?
Ew.
Oh.
That's my pet.
What's my pet sound?
My pet is right here, right here.
Right here!
My friend Dio and Jeff.
Oh!
Dio and Jeff.
Yeah, Dio and Jeff.
Get inside.
Oh, jump, jump.
Skill issue, Dio.
I'm getting good.
What are they?
They are...
Oh, Mouse is here.
Mousey!
It's okay.
Day
nine.
Day nine.
When you have a pickaxe and when you get close to them,
they're going to get scared because they saw they were going
to mind them.
Oh, I do it.
No!
I don't want to kill!
Um, I can use...
I have nothing to...
Oh, I have...
This.
Stay back.
Oh, that's for building.
That's for building.
Oh.
Yeah, that's Olympic.
I can give you one, ladies.
Okay.
And here's my...
There's so many...
So many signs.
I know.
Thanks to Zed.
Oh.
Whoa.
We have a lot of mods in here.
here so there's a lot of like a new decorations and stuff
everything looks new yeah i'm seeing have you ever played
modern minecraft before no it's my first time oh it was
first time for me too but a lot of people will teach you
because people are so nice in here so yeah you'll love it
you'll love it wow oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and this is my
kitchen well i can't see anything right now Oh, I can't see
anything.
Long, long, long.
I have a panda.
Yeah, I have a panda.
Uh-oh, Henya, thank you.
Do you want me to do your dishes for you?
Oh yeah, really?
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm amazed.
It's been sitting there for like six months.
Thank you.
No problem.
I'll clean it with my tongue.
You know?
She's like a made dragon.
Oh, but yeah, she's on.
Oh, you're a made dragon?
No, I'm made ghosts, you know.
Same thing.
Thank you for cleaning.
Maybe I can do it by myself too.
Thank you.
My mom will take care of it.
Oh, are you sure I'll clean the whole kitchen, you know?
No, no, it's your first time.
You should enjoy this place.
Well, what about we go somewhere else?
Okay.
Okay, no worries.
Oh, I think Mouse is here.
Oh, look.
I think you can get out from here.
The door.
I gotta fix this one.
Mousey!
Oh, my God.
You look like a Gaia Online crazy character.
Whoa.
Hello.
What's this?
Honey.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, so cute!
Hi, Bowser!
Yummy!
It's yummy!
Oh
my gosh, Jesus- I was showing her a lot of places.
I was wondering where should I take her.
You want to see other people's house?
Yeah!
I want to see everything!
Everything, Mario!
Everything!
How about we go to...
house okay oh wait before that maybe we can go look at the
art gallery too okay oh yeah you're gonna have so much fun
in here oh my god there's so much oh you finished the art
let's see it so this is art gallery the mouse built it you
built it oh my god yeah and we put that a lot of fan art in
here.
Yoshi's sign, post it on the art wall.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
That looks so cool.
Oh, it's so cute!
I know!
Every month she's going to put out the new art for the month
and she keeps taking it every month.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, it looks so good.
Oh.
I love this one.
It looks perfect.
Yeah.
I like it, too.
Here we go.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, cute.
A bow in front.
This is where I'm going to make my house right here.
In front of this one.
Right here.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
This is from Hell Divers.
club oh this is so cute i love it i made an honorable
honorable entry into the art gallery uh she's going to put
the a guest picture too she said oh cute yeah wasn't it
third floor was the third floor mouse we're in the first and
second two third floor i'm not finished oh okay i'm excited
to see it then i'm excited to see it then
I love I can see the people's art in the Minecraft as well
like you can download it and you can like you can you can
see that like your favorite picture on the Minecraft as well
yeah that's what I said sexy we need an r18 part of the
gallery don't apologize
It's art.
Yeah, it's art.
There actually will be one.
This one's so cute.
Oh, cute!
This one is like really fancy.
It's called Hentai and it's art.
Oh.
Oh, that's cute.
Yo-ho, yo-ho, a pirate life for me.
Oh, I like this one.
I like how Henya is, like, experiencing it, too.
Yeah, this is my first time seeing it for this month.
Oh!
It's so cute.
Jinja, every month.
Does it take a long time, or?
Yeah.
A whole day!
There's so much too.
You said there was a second story?
Second floor?
Yeah, there's a stairs like...
Oh, I see!
Yeah, you can go there!
Three floors.
Oh my gosh!
Whoa!
Boing, boing da yo.
Boing, boing everywhere da yo.
You have good taste, Mouse.
You have good taste.
Sometimes we get the art of...
Wow, indeed.
Wow, wow, wow.
I was like, what does she hold?
Oh, those are cuffs.
Oh my gosh.
So pretty.
Oh, this one's so cute.
What about you and Mata floating in there?
Oh my god!
That'd be so cute!
Eee!
Oh!
Awaiii!
No, I love this one!
It's so cute!
Oh yeah!
This one is so cute too!
What's for the...
That outfit is from the anime collab one!
That looks so cute!
That's so cute!
Oh, I like the Zen one too.
Aww, this one is cute too!
Cute!
Everything's so cute!
I know!
I love modern Minecraft.
There's so much stuff that you can do.
Oh my god.
It's like they're 3D.
It's like they're gonna jump out of the screen at me.
Dekai.
Dekai!
Cute!
You can't go Go back.
I remember seeing this one on Twitter.
Which one?
The comic of you and Haruka.
She says, since we're here, let's go out.
And your eyes say no.
This one is my favorite too.
No da yo.
Never da yo.
Simple.
Easy.
No da yo.
Simple and easy.
Never going outside.
Oh, there's a ladder over here too.
to go to a Sith boy.
Oh.
Here we go.
Oh,
there are still...
Oh, my God.
Oh, cute!
Gengar!
That's my boy right there.
Gengar.
Me too, Mousy.
Yeah, I love Gengar too.
I'll play a game with only Gengar.
Sometimes.
Really?
Yeah, we all Pokemon with just Gengar.
Gengar dao.
Oh, Gengar dao.
Gengar.
So yeah, this is an art gallery we have.
It's so beautiful.
Down there, we have a post office too.
Would you like to look at it?
Oh yeah.
Let's go.
Okay.
Where is the stairs again?
Uh, this way?
This way, this way.
There's so many buildings now.
There's so many buildings.
It's so active in here.
It is.
There's so many people in the server as well.
That's so awesome.
Yeah, it is!
Oh, here.
I'm gonna get lost.
It's so huge.
Pop-pada-pada-pada-pada.
Here's the, here's the post office that we have.
Also, mouse filled this one too.
Ooh, I like these doors.
Fancy.
Ooh, fancy.
I think you can use this place to send them a gift and
letter to people.
Wait, real?
I do have a mailbox.
So once you place the mailbox, you put the stuff in here.
They will deliver it to your mailbox automatically.
Yeah, click right here.
Click this one.
Right click.
Oh!
Whoa!
Okay.
I'm gonna start sending creepy letters to everybody.
Yeah, it's so fun.
It's so fun.
It's so cool.
This is so cool.
Oh my god.
Ah!
There's here, O'Brien.
Hair, Brian!
What the heck?
I think he works here.
I think so.
Didn't know.
Didn't know Mousy got the new employee.
It's a hair, O'Brien.
Hey, do your job, O'Brien.
He helps out a lot.
Oh, good.
Maybe.
Keep doing your job.
Maybe he'll get a raise one day, O'Brien.
Cars.
The garage is so funny.
Yeah, we have a garage door.
And also...
Oh, this is a portal for Nezer.
So if you go in here, you go to the Nezer.
Are we going?
Uh, we can if you want.
Here we go.
Oh.
Except me.
Somehow bound to S-Control or something instead.
They're trying to buy it.
It's just regular control.
Whoa!
Even the nether is, like, so different too.
Yeah, I was gonna say it's so different.
It's a lot different.
You'll love it.
We even said that it, like, introduced itself.
The nether.
Oh, look over there.
Blue Forest Palace.
Whoa!
Oh!
It's so blue.
Oh my god.
It's so beautiful.
It is, it is!
Wow.
They have a lot of cool stuff too, so I hope you enjoy it.
Oh, the lights!
Wait, who's that?
There's an old man walking around.
Old man?
Yeah, I think so.
What?
Ah!
Oh.
The traveling merchant.
Oh, he's just in here?
Oh!
He's chilling in here.
Wait, he's here?
Is it a nether?
Oh my.
You're gonna die, mister.
Why the heck he's in here?
You're gonna die in here.
On point, Nito villager.
Nito villager.
Yeah.
Nito villager, what are you doing in here?
It's actually unemployed.
Why even here?
Ah!
Oh, what just happened?
What?
What's that sound?
Oh, that's a hook shot.
Oh, I thought I was gonna- I thought I was about to die.
What was that?
Oh, the village looks really different too from the vanilla
Minecraft.
It's a lot bigger.
Wait, so there's different biomes and stuff too?
Would you like to see it?
Yeah!
Okay, oh, uh, when you...
When you type slash spawn, you can go back to the spawn area
anytime.
Oh, okay.
Slash spawn.
That's it?
Yeah, and send.
Oh!
Oh, that's crazy.
See?
It's so good.
No, I did not see the pink house.
This is so cursed.
The pink house?
Wait, that looks so cute though.
Oh, pink house.
Okay, hold on.
Skelly, should I...
Mint!
Hello?
Hit you!
Oh, it's so good to see you!
Mint, mouse!
I'm being led.
I don't know what's going on.
Mint, welcome to the server.
I got these for you.
Me?
And I made you spaghetti.
Spaghetti?
You can make spaghetti?
Wait, how do I get it?
Grab this- Oh!
Oh!
Thank you!
It's so exciting that you're here!
Oh my gosh!
I'm gonna eat it.
Oh!
You're putting your mouth!
I- I- I- I got an achievement.
Whoa!
Yippee!
And mama mia!
Mama mia!
Mama!
I blew up the dam.
Oh, thank you.
You're so welcome.
Has she seen the museum?
Yeah, we just did.
She just got here.
So far, we saw...
Oh, my gosh.
The museum is the best part.
Yeah, you have to see the swap.
Oh, the swap?
Is this one over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, hold on.
I live in this...
You can get out from here.
This way, this way.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Okay.
Here we go.
Let's go swamp.
Swamp.
Oh my god.
Isn't it all content?
Oh yeah.
Matta gave it to me.
You can feed him fish or honey.
I have honey.
Yeah, if you throw a honeycomb at him, he holds it in his
hand and he eats it.
It's so cute.
It's so sticky cute.
I think the pandas, I think they do that too.
Yeah, yeah, that's so cute.
That's true.
Oh, oh.
Light as a frog.
What did I, what did I become?
Oh, touch the waste.
If you're ever missing any resources, you just go into that
spooky little temple back there, and you can just take
whatever's in there.
That one over there?
Yeah.
I made the house and the temple.
Can I go see the temple?
Yeah, whatever you need anything, you can just go inside
there and you can just take it.
It's free.
You can just take it.
Am I gonna die?
No, no, no, no.
You're just going to make a deal.
Make a deal?
Oh, that's easy.
Yeah.
Oh.
Whoa.
In here, in here.
Touch the computer.
Oh.
Whoa!
Whoa, there's so much stuff in here!
You should make one too.
You don't need to make a warehouse.
It's all the stuff I've collected.
What the hell?
Oh my god!
There's so much here!
There's a bunch of chests down here.
And when you connect it with these terminals, like you just
need to put the random stuff in the chest.
Or you can put it in from here.
And they'll do like all the organizing and everything by
their self.
So you don't need to deal with it.
Wait, my crouch isn't working!
Um, hold on, let me try changing it again.
I don't know why my key bind directing funny.
Wait, I didn't know you could actually go inside of the
storage.
Yeah, you can!
Wait, how- I want to see how many chests you have.
I want to see how nuts it is.
It's from here, it's here, it's here.
You see the, like, a pipeline?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go down there.
Wait, let me see your chests.
Let me see your chests.
Oh, there's a ha- Oh!
Oh my gosh!
It's setting to add S.
I don't know why.
Froggy!
Huh?
What about pressing C?
Can you do this?
C?
C.
Yeah!
Oh, I can do the C.
Did you change it?
Something just happened!
Oh, I don't know what's going on.
Oh!
Uh...
Hold on!
Oh no!
I think I messed up.
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh!
What's going on?
It's okay, it's okay.
You can do it.
You can come over here anytime.
Okay!
I'll come.
uh right now oh wait i think i yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
wait i think okay what the why is it not working click
delete take your time take your time i'm sorry
what is going on
Now both are bound to see.
No, because I reset it, though.
Oh, you did it?
Does it still work?
Um.
Sorry, I was yelling at Ari.
Oh, see, this is what's bound to open wardrobe.
We'll do.
Let me peep that chest.
I'm trying to peep that chest.
Peep that chest.
Oh my god!
Egg!
Yeah!
If I do like pee.
What the heck?
Holy crap!
I don't know.
Oh wait a second.
Oh wait a minute.
I can- I can D-P you I guess.
Hold on.
Oh I guess that's true.
What do you think I'll see something crazy?
What do you have in here?
Hold on.
Let me go inside here.
I'm gonna do this kid.
I don't know
why the CNS are here.
Did you get the request?
Oh, I did!
Wait, so I do X.
Oh!
Oh, there you go!
You got it!
Whoa!
This is a warehouse you have.
Oh my god.
My computer is chunking.
I'm playing at two frames per second right now.
I know.
This room is in this room.
is uh beefy holy smokes oh what is this thing inventory
cable oh my god when you have this you just place a random
stuff and uh you don't need to make a warehouse you just
need a big room with a bowl of chess whoa oh it's easy to
set up too it takes everything it's a computer that lets
access your stuff what that's crazy yeah you should have one
you should have one it's easy to make one oh my modded
minecraft is amazing it is oh there's a waste on over here
put your stuff in the inventory oh there's a waste stone in
here even yeah right
here three ton services pressing the button while pressing
delete Okay, let me try.
No.
Mint keybys are spugged and might be have to reset the
config file.
Wait, really?
Yeah, they're kind of weird.
Yeah, it's a little weird, but only for sneak.
I don't know why.
Wah!
You got a gift from Mousa.
Oh!
Oh, I got diamonds!
Oh.
Oh, that's a lot of that.
Thank you, Allison!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Yay!
I'm gonna hold on to them.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, bouquet!
Oh, Robbie gave you that.
They're my color.
Oh my gosh, you're right!
Oh, I was saying, mwah!
Mwah!
Welcome.
Hi, Ii!
You have three minutes to escape before your computer
explodes.
What will you do?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
No!
It's so laggy!
Stop, you're making the lag white!
You're only making it worse!
You're gonna explode your PC if you keep doing that!
Oh, okay.
So slash spawn?
Yeah, so I spawn.
Okay!
Oh Ewe There you go.
There you go My house is next to Yeah, let's go.
Let's go set it on fire Yeah, yeah, also Gorda we have this
one too.
This one too Lucky fox casino.
Wait, we have casino.
Why are you crying?
Look at it!
I got zero dollars!
I'm broke, da yo!
No, no.
I lost my money.
A skill issue da yo, skill issue da yo.
Well, let's see if you have a good look.
Okay.
A good skill da yo.
One item at a time.
Send here and wait.
Thank you, thank you!
What do I wait for?
Oh.
So you put the item, something valuable inside there, and
you send And ride this.
Oh!
Okay, I'll throw a diamond.
And wait for it.
Oh!
You got something!
Look at it!
What is this?
I got a gold block!
Oh my god!
Nice!
Oh, how do I get out?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, did I did it?
Did it work?
Oh, I hear something.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, my god.
Ah!
Help me!
Hey!
Oh.
Where'd she go?
I'm up here!
Oh, hi!
Hi!
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Oh, hi!
I think, uh, I think, um, what happened there?
Oh!
It's fine, it's fine.
Yeah, I noticed we don't lose anything.
It's so awesome.
Yay!
No penalty.
Yep.
Yeah, when you die, you're not gonna lost your stuff like in
the vanilla Minecraft.
Yeah, it's so nice.
You keep your item.
We used to have you had a gravestone, but we had too many
gravestones and that caused a lag, so we had to remove it.
Yep, yep, yep.
I get it.
That's okay.
You know, who cares about the dead, right?
Yeah, who cares about the dead?
Yeah.
And this one is a dead house.
Oh, you have to go up from here.
Okay.
Her house is like, needs a technique to go up.
Don't worry about it, Mosey.
Wait, where is it?
Where'd you go?
up here you see that you see that waterfall oh yeah yeah and
you go up oh okay
okay i won't drown
it's like a it's lapido yeah it's like a lapido our house is
like a lapido she has a little aquarium over here there's a
fishy Oh my god.
Crab rave.
There are so many new mobs in the ocean too.
So I hope you enjoy it.
Yeah, it's so awesome.
There's so many.
Everything.
There's so much.
Yeah, it is.
Wow.
Sunfish.
We have bosses and everything.
Oh my gosh.
What?
That's crazy.
Yeah, I want to be so many bosses.
I have so many bosses to be.
What's this?
And then, that's a vent house over there.
You see the pink building?
That's a vent house.
Oh, okay, okay.
This one?
Oh.
Oh, I thought I was about to die.
Oh, be careful.
There are so many holes in the ground.
Oh, I saw this picture from down there.
Oh, really?
Uh, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm here for a big present.
I gave this art to every single one of them house and yeah!
What?
So if I build a house, will I get one?
Yeah, of course!
You'll get one too!
Oh my god, it will be my honor.
You're already a Giga-chan!
Oh, I think you!
You too, Daya!
Oh, I think Sintoya clogged her toilet.
Eww!
Wait, what is this?
Isn't that a...
Is this a person?
Oh!
I think he was using the bathroom.
He didn't wash his hands.
Nasty.
Eww!
He's so cute, actually.
He got the microwave!
What the heck, Zen?
You got the salad in the microwave?
Shaking my head, Zen.
Sentreya from V-Shojo, shaking my head.
Um...
I'll just set it to 500 minutes.
Oh, nice, nice.
Make it to 1000, 1000 minutes.
Yeah, 1000 minutes.
Oh, I almost fell out.
Ouch.
Are you okay?
Yep, I'm okay.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah.
What is this?
Oh, it's a cat!
Why does it sound like that?
Yeah, it's a cat though.
Oh, that's a lipid.
That's a lipid as well.
Oh.
When you go up here.
Oh, there's more.
I think this is her bedroom, I guess.
Mm-hmm.
There's a... Wait, there's a Herobrine again.
What's a maid here, O'Brien?
Wait a minute, I thought he's at a post office.
He's in tier two?
Maybe she's renting this to him.
Maybe, maybe.
This is a limpet.
It's...
It's like Gary from SpongeBob.
Oh, wait, that's true.
Meow.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Zen.
Do you think these will fit me?
Oh, my God, the center of her hole!
Ah!
Oh, my God, so cute!
Oh, my gosh.
No way.
Yeah, it looks so cute.
Look.
I'm looking.
Ta-ta-da-da.
Is there like a little buddy?
Ting cinnamon!
It's so cute!
The card for my birthday!
Oh my god, that's so sweet!
Aww.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
He's my god.
I pray to your god.
Dun dun dun.
It's so adorable.
Oh my gosh.
I like your digital hat too.
The digital hat looks really cute too.
a Dejiko hat.
I thought it was.
Yeah, it is a Dejiko hat.
I like it a lot.
Me too!
Oh my gosh.
He even has the bells and everything.
Oh, I think she's asking you.
Oh.
Sorry, sorry.
There we go.
No, it's okay.
If you want to try it on, I'll sniff it after.
No, it's your day.
It's your day.
Oh my god, it's so cute.
Oh, cute!
I thought it's so cute.
I gotta find Thank you!
Wait, is it...
Is it just to borrow or have...
If I get another one.
Oh, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Fight to the death?
Um...
I can... I have a Death by... Death by Burger.
Ah!
Death by Burger.
Um, I wish I could take her panties and whack them, whack
you with them.
Well, you, I'm pretty sure you can make one really, really
soon.
It's easy to make one, so if you want pints, you get it
Can I wear them on my head?
Oh, wait a minute, I have perfect one for you.
I have perfect one for you.
Uh-oh, now I'm scared.
Can you see the discord?
Uh, yeah, yeah, I can see.
I think you'll love it.
Okay.
Everybody can use it.
There you go.
Here, perfect for you.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna put it on right now.
Yeah, do it, do it, do it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Give me one second, everybody.
This is important, this is important stuff going on.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna lurk your street.
I'm gonna live your stream.
One moment everybody.
There he is.
There he is, Chad.
He's doing it.
That's a perfect fit!
What do you guys think?
Yay!
It's a perfect fit I think!
I'm gonna learn to!
Matching!
This is my uniform, everybody.
This is, uh...
This is...
I... I...
This is my magical girl uniform.
You look perfect, though.
Thank you.
Oh, booty girl!
Wait, that actually suits Enya so much?
Iron Mouse gave you a... she gave you a...
Poochico?
Oh, thank you, Mouse!
Thank you!
Oh!
It's a Poochico from Dejiko Cat.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thank you, Maus!
Thank you!
Oh, that's so cute!
I like it!
Thank you!
Oh, I'll never take it off.
I'll never take it off.
It's such a...
Yay!
Now we're watching.
We are.
Where else is there?
Okay.
Okay, the next one is...
I think it's her...
Her house?
I think this one last one from this house okay yeah yeah
yeah oh she also got a mini mart as well she made it like a
little market as well oh it's on it this way okay oh i see
it everything's in the sky she's building a sky village whoa
sky town What kind of snacks do they have here?
They got some cool snacks, they got shopping cart, they got
wine, they got apples, radish.
Well they have everything.
Apples.
We got everything in here.
And we got the cash register over here.
I'm just gonna steal.
Yeah, steal there.
She's not gonna notice.
Yeah, she's not gonna notice.
Yeah.
Let's rob this place.
This place is so tall.
I can't see anything.
Me neither.
This place is so tall.
We need a small people market.
Yeah!
Everything is so tall now!
But that means maybe we get bigger size and so...
It lasts longer for us.
Because we're so small.
This is the best one.
So that's a Zen house.
Uh...
I'm okay.
Obviously.
No problem.
We should make her a mermaid.
Yeah, we should.
How do I make it again?
Mermaid.
It's cool.
She can make it.
Oh my god.
She's a genius.
Oh, so are you.
Maybe...
Mouse is more of a genius.
Wait, what do you mean?
I am the genius, though.
Yeah, but she's making...
She made the mermaid!
Oh.
Thank you!
Wait, I just wear this?
Mm-hmm.
And then I become a mermaid?
There you go.
You're a mermaid now.
Oh, I am.
Oh, my God.
Oh, look at my tail.
Yeah, look at you.
You can change a color, too.
Yeah, you'll never drown.
And you're so fast, though.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
You guys, I'm a mermaid.
I want to be where the people are.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Under the sea!
Thank you, Mousy!
Thank you!
Wow!
Modern Minecraft does everything.
And this one right here is Melody's house.
Oh!
Oh my god, the cinnamon roll.
Yeah, Melody built it.
Melody built it.
What is this brick?
It's a white concrete and a white metal book.
It's high-end, packed, silto.
Silto.
So cute!
Yeah!
It is, it is!
Oh my gosh, so pretty!
Oh my gosh.
All the houses look so nice.
I love the windows!
F5.
For what?
Now home!
Cute!
What's this?
Oh, Silver and Bill, what is this?
Oh, cute.
There's a cat, everybody- Oh, the cats sleeping are so cute!
Oh my god, wait.
I know, it's so cute!
I'm inside Mel's bed.
I don't know, this might be kind of yabai.
It's okay, she doesn't know, she doesn't know.
I don't know.
Oh.
We are in.
How's the smell?
It smells.
Hmm.
Also she has a pet as well.
She has a pet as well.
Huh?
Yeah.
Come to come to the backyard.
Backyard?
Yeah.
Oh, in here?
Look!
Oh, in here!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Is he gonna eat me?
Oh, bad, bad, bad dragon.
Can I ride?
I think he's not hungry today.
Oh, can I ride on his back?
Yeah, you can try.
Come on.
Out!
Wait!
Come here.
Oh.
What's happening?
He's a scary.
He's a bad dragon.
He's scary.
Yeah, he's bad.
You're mean bad dragon.
Bad dragon.
I want to make a hat out of him.
Where are these melodies playing?
I will kill him.
It's okay.
Oh, I can probably...
Wait, I don't want to hit him either just in case.
I don't know what his health is like.
He's so cool, though.
I want to...
I want him.
Maybe I can push him in the back, or...
Oh, okay.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Sasuka, I'm out of here.
So, yeah.
This is a Melody's place.
I think she's building it.
a new one somewhere.
It's so cute.
Oh my god.
The trees even.
Wow.
Oh yeah, it's here, isn't it?
Wow, it's going to be.
Magnolia.
It's so pretty.
A lot of pretty trees.
Yeah.
We have so many trees and it's so pretty.
So that's a Mousy's place.
cool and uh next one here we go so the next one oh this is a
Camilla's house as well with my amazing art that I have yes
oh and the next one oh oh um we're in the prayer this is a
crudels place oh wow well he had an open door field but he
stole my watermelon, so Mouse and I and Addy decided to
cover his entire place with a watermelon.
Ah!
Paybacker!
Yeah, paybacker!
I think it looks so much better like this.
Yeah!
I like it too!
I like the art of him getting attacked.
He's building a train for this area.
And Giga-chan-henya!
Yeah, Giga-chan-henya!
Exactly.
Oh my gosh, If I steal from Henya, what will you create?
Oh, you'll see it.
You'll see it though.
Oh wow.
Oh, he really likes these spinning things.
Yeah, there are so many things in here.
Yeah.
Wait, he made a train!
I wanna get on!
Wait, it's actually...
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
He's making a train run!
Oh my gosh, it's a hell burn again.
Oh, oh!
Oh!
It's so fast!
It is!
Why are there so many endermens here?
Oh, I hear a spider too.
Is this dangerous?
Wait!
That's so cool!
He's making it true!
One shot kill.
I will protect.
Okay, Mousy!
I leave it to you!
Oh, and I... Oh!
Are you okay?
No, don't get hit by train!
How do we get on the train though?
It's so fast.
It is.
I tried it but I couldn't though.
Okay, I'm gonna run at it.
What the heck?
So close.
But yeah, he has a lot of stuff over here.
There's even a hair around here.
I think you can use it.
Over here?
He has a lot of cool stuff.
I don't really know how to use it because I'm not really
know about Creed and Mod, but he got a lot of cool things
over here.
Yeah, live, laugh, love.
Oh my gosh, it's really working in there.
What was that?
I feel like I'm playing a new game.
Yeah, this is completely different.
I think you all love it because this is so cool.
Yeah.
It's a lot of cool things over here.
Oh, that's what?
I don't know.
The water.
Yeah.
So it's okay if you go in.
What?
What just happened?
I was trying to push you in.
And then I thought something exploded.
Here we go.
Oh, that's her hammer.
Oh.
Want to try it?
The hammer?
Ah!
Oh!
Wow.
No!
What do you mean?
You all killed me!
What's going on again?
Oh, there we go.
Hello.
Hello!
Welcome back.
mouse you bonged me to death a strong super bong super bong
not kiss my feet kiss my feet
thank you thank you
wow what else is there no it's okay is this jail right here
i i don't know what this is it's a jail i'm going in jail
gonna make a huge prison oh yeah oh nice so we should put
zen in there yeah and matara oh also there's a lot of cool
houses over there want to see it yeah i want to see
Everything.
Oh!
There we go.
This way.
Whoa!
So that's the place we just went.
Oh wow, there's even smiling up top.
The Savannah.
Giraffes!
Look!
This is Addy's house.
Whoa!
There's a giraffe.
There's an elephant.
There's a lot of money.
There are!
They are!
He is so cute!
I know, right?
He's so cute!
He's dying too!
Yeah!
What happened?
What happened to you, giraffe?
I love this tree!
It's a flower that puts a dog.
I like this one too!
What'd you call it?
Hello!
Hi!
I like your tree!
Yeah, I have them here for your materials.
It's not going to like stay looking like this, but I thought
it would also be pretty to like grow some of these and then
get rid of the leaves and swap them out with some of these
blue and purple ones.
Oh, they'll be good.
Wait, this one is like blue color.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm gonna like swap them out.
So I'm using it for material.
Mouse.
Uh oh.
Oh.
Mouse.
She's on the hunt.
Oh, there's a thing.
I've done nothing wrong.
It is so cute though.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
I'm intruding.
I don't have any furniture in it just yet.
Because I'm working on a basement right now.
But.
Oh, you basement.
You're a house?
Alright, come on, Mouse.
Let's go for a while.
This is here.
Excuse me.
Hey, where'd you go?
I'm inside.
Oh, you're inside?
Oh, you're inside.
Hello.
Sorry.
There's a mouse!
Oh, do it for her.
The shrine.
You gotta do it for Mouse.
I own Ari's soul.
It's true.
I need this boat for Athenia.
Oh yeah, that would be really cute.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm gonna make yours too, then I can put it on my house.
Really?
Yeah!
We can do it together.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I don't have any furniture in here just yet.
Your house is so cute.
Yeah, it's peanut.
I love it.
Wait, how do you change a dog again?
So I put the name tag, I named it Husky, and then I put it
on the dog and it changed the name.
That is so cute.
Husky.
It is so cute.
And here's a problem.
Your problem is dying.
Listen, I would appreciate my problems going away.
your problem has nine lives would you like my problem but
but but it's your cat it's your cat that's my problem
you're not a problem no not for a problem poor problem took
me an hour to catch oh he's facing the wall he's in time out
yeah he's in time out oh Shame a corner Yeah, but I've been
I've been working on um This basement down here Oh Can we
see it?
Yeah, I don't have like the hallway for it done just yet So
it's kind of ominous It's just this It's a little scary
getting down to it But the down here looks really really
pretty Oh Oh wait a minute I love this fish tank Yeah I
haven't finished decorating this just yet That's so awesome!
And then I'm underwater down here.
I'm gonna put a bunch of fun fish out there when I'm done.
Oh my, I love it!
That's such a good idea.
Yeah, I'm still working on it.
Wow!
That looks so good!
What is that?
Oh, it's one of those pretty glowfish out there.
Oh my god, it's so cute!
It sings, like, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Yeah, they whistle.
Cool!
It's so pretty!
Oh my god, it's so cute.
Yeah, I'm gonna put a bunch of really cool fish out there.
and then axolotl in here because axolotl eat other fish yeah
yeah i'm gonna decorate this tank and make it really pretty
and then keep only axolotl in here oh cute cute there's so
many axolotls in here it's not only like four colors they
have so many yeah what if i break i mean you could mouse but
why would you uh-oh why would you break it uh-oh look at it
she's a tiny menace Oh my mouse.
Just kidding, I won't do it.
Give in to your inner demons, your outer demons, your
demons.
Embrace the demon.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I got a good distraction.
Hold on.
Oh yeah.
Let me put this up.
Touch the doorbell.
There you go.
Does this appease you?
Oh!
Does this appease you, mouse?
Oh no!
She stole it!
Froggy!
Why are you at my door?
Look yourself in!
Can I come in?
Yeah!
Okay, thank you!
My doorbell's a little violent.
Oh my god, so cute!
It's so cute!
It's like sitting on the ground!
Oh, that's adorable!
It's so cute!
here.
Cinnamon, cinnamon.
I love it.
It looks like it's actually here.
It does, it does.
Who added, who added the soup?
Oh my god, that's so cute!
It is cute, kawaii.
Look at how short they all are.
It's not a music disc, does anybody need this?
Are you wearing a Sonic hat?
Yeah!
It makes me sparkle!
It sounds like it's cute!
That's why you're sparkling, that's so cool.
It's so cute!
Yeah, Mosh gave it to me.
Oh.
Wait, you're wearing a Pikmin hat.
I just realized that you've been wearing a Pikmin hat this
whole time.
No, it's a Puchiko!
Puchiko from...
What?
Puchiko!
But it's got the flower on the head.
No, Pikumi has like a long tailed, like a pointy thing in
it.
What do I do with him?
Oh, you're right, you're right!
I thought it was the yellow pigment.
Oh, he's hot!
Also, how do you have cinema roll like flying around you
now?
Yeah, what?
How did you do that?
Why did all these cinema rolls come from?
Wait, I'm- Oh my god, I'm snowing!
Oh!
Oh, wait, that's adorable!
You got a little snowman on your head!
Snow high, Sean!
That's so cute!
Oh my god.
There's snowflakes around you.
Yeah.
That is so, so cute.
That's cute.
Oh my gosh, you have so much stuff.
How do you get the hats?
You have to find them, I think.
Oh.
Yeah, you have to find them.
There's a lot of places that you can go.
There's a cave and there's a treasure chest inside there so
you can get it from there.
Excuse me!
Ari!
Okay.
I'll come to you.
I'll make a pact.
I'll sell my soul.
I only have, I am a soul.
I wouldn't say that, Mitt.
Only one favorite part.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll make a deal.
Wonderful.
Yeah.
It's okay, I'm already dead.
It's okay.
You can't say no.
Don't worry.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, years from now.
Don't, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No worries, no worries.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What could go wrong?
Nothing.
I trust, yeah.
4K faith.
Yeah, that's not an exaggeration.
It's true, it's true.
I have quite the debt.
Hey, oh my my, you own a lot, Ari.
Yeah, the amount of gold blocks that I asked Miss for is a
lot.
Oh, that's true, that's true.
You own a lot, Dio.
Yeah, she made my beacon for me.
I didn't even make it.
She made it herself.
The block underneath it, too, right?
This was like a mouse made it, right?
Yeah.
She did it all with that.
Yeah, she got the nether star and everything.
She killed the wither for me.
Yeah, Mouse kind of owns me.
I remember I spawned the wither thinking that I could kill
it And then I started killing me So I was said to come save
me and kill it Wait, how do you sit down again?
Oh, you look at the ground and you double tap shift
Brains I ain't got one I need one Hanya
I don't know how she did.
She was like spamming sit, so I guess she just...
Oh my God, Anya.
Oh, if I give you this, rest in peace.
Oh, wait, how do I throw it?
How do I throw things?
Kiel?
Hello.
Oh, you're giving away the flower bouquet!
I got you!
No, it was for her!
It was for her grave!
I took those flowers and you keep them, you keep them, Okay,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm
sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
How do you sit?
You look at the ground and you double tap shift.
Oh, wait, my thing doesn't...
Oh, my thing doesn't work.
That's right.
My crouch is broken.
You end up going to the ground like Kenya.
Uh-oh.
Wait, why did I go up in the ground?
I don't know.
I think you're just spam sit somewhere.
much you just face through the ground you could get like
some wool blocks and put them down as we'll be bags oh
what's going on oh you got it you got it oh something's
happening to me she's freaking so what's going on i can't
move where are you going i can't go anywhere else I can't...
I'm stuck!
I can't go nowhere else to go!
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm normal.
It's so beautiful.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm learning their motor controls.
I am.
Yeah,
yeah!
Yeah!
I finally fixed my storage, I think.
If I remember?
I want to see it.
basement or I fixed it and I can't remember great uh-uh-uh
not if I didn't fix it just like Pete no if I didn't oh yeah
yeah yeah it's good as Pete looks yeah yeah yeah yeah what's
sniffing so much it's the bear in my house it's aco riding
oh yeah did you show them aco riding what he's been
wandering the house I don't know who let him in oh I found
him when he's almost dead No!
No!
Oh, there he is.
What is this?
According to all known laws of aviation.
No, it's not according, it's acoriting.
Oh, you're right.
Don't make fun of me!
Oh, you met him!
He's so cute!
Yeah, you won't see him?
You won't see him?
Oh, oh, oh, thank you.
Yeah, just throw one at him.
Throw it?
Okay.
Yeah, you just throw it at him.
When he's done eating that one, he'll pick it up.
Slurp it down!
Oh my god, he's so cute!
He's so cute!
Oh, father!
That's so cute!
I love him!
Yeah, you love him!
How do you heal him?
I think I need to like, throw like a splash potion of
healing on him.
Oh!
Oh, he's sniffing.
Oh, yeah, because Froggy's holding one, so he won't.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
His nose is so bouncy.
Boing, boing, boing, boing, boing, boing, boing.
Yeah, I'll go riding.
Boing, boing, boing, boing.
He's so cute.
I love the little head tail.
Yeah, he's so cute.
He's so cute.
He's so good.
Wait, have you ever seen Meatball?
No, what's that?
Meatball!
Remember Minion you named him?
What?
Oh yeah!
A meatball!
Meatball!
Where is he?
He's over here.
Meatball.
I'm so jealous that Heavenly lets you peep heads.
It's demonic wizard meatball.
Oh right!
Demonic wizard meatball!
Damonic wizard meatball!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow.
He's named after him.
heavenly oh i love when he looks directly at the camera i
love it if you like press z to zoom in on him he'll like
just stare at you really weird it's funny wait you can zoom
in zooming in on my map i think my keybinds are all weird
look at you wait we love him he's staring at you yeah hold
on i want to see if he'll look at me He's got an attitude
problem today.
Meatball!
Oh my god, he listened!
Oh my god!
He's so good.
You're a good listener, Meatball.
I love how chunky he really likes you.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, his eyes.
Yeah, yeah, he's looking at you.
Yeah!
I love him so much.
He's so silly.
He's so cute.
But yeah, Froggy's place is this way.
This way.
Oh yeah, it's the giant mushroom.
Mushroom.
Oh, I see it.
I was waiting till you came back around.
I expanded this corner of the grass a little bit.
Hell yeah.
It didn't really disturb your bridge.
I just had to relocate some lily pads.
I don't mind if you touch my lily pads if you don't have
faith.
Oh, cute.
You can go grab mouse so mouse has to get up behind.
Fireflies.
There's even fireflies.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, I have a bunch of them if you want them.
I accidentally made a ton.
I actually made too many.
I have a lot of them.
You're a breeder.
You've bred the fireflies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go over here.
This is my house.
Okay.
Oh, jamaishimasu!
Oh, so cute!
Thank you!
You can sit.
Oh, hubby.
What?
Oh, I'm sitting!
We gotta show him but let me see if I can even find but I
don't know where but again I hope he's okay.
There is.
Wait.
Uh oh.
He's in the plant.
Let me try and get him.
I'm stuck.
Oh no, where are you?
Ah, the worm is in here too.
They're both in here.
Thank you.
What the heck?
Oh, where are you from?
This one.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This way, this way.
Oh, this one.
Thank you.
I can't get him out of the plants.
I can't pick him up.
This is Froggy's place.
Smells like a frog.
Try so hard.
I can't get him.
I give up.
Frog.
Frog smell.
Froggy.
If you pick the plant up, you can get him out.
If I pick the plant up, I was thinking of picking up the
box.
What a crazy setup.
Is this dynamite?
No!
Uh-uh!
There are no explosives in this house.
Never mind, I saw nothing.
I saw nothing.
I'm no fett.
I'm no snitch.
You got a cake?
Yeah!
So cute!
Coffee.
What the hell was that?
I can't pick... I can't pick them up anymore.
Did he get bigger?
There's stuff in the fridge!
There's raw pasta.
Oh, my cup!
Oh, ha ha ha ha.
I knew that I knew that You can actually do cooking in this
game You can?
Yeah You need a bunch of different kinds of pots to cook So
I've got like a ton of different pots Oh my god Oh I see it
Oh small cooking What?
That's crazy It's really cute It gives you a buff So yeah
it's really great Cool Yeah And then my unfinished basement
is down there And then my room is up here Oh, you have a
little man in here.
What?
Oh, yeah, Steve.
Steve.
Wait, what?
There's a tiny man in my house?
Yeah, he's in your basement.
What?
He's looking at your chest.
Yeah.
What?
Huh?
Uh.
Yeah, he's...
I think he's stealing yourself.
Oh, oh, my.
Oh, my heart.
Oh, my gosh.
That's what you meant.
What did you think?
I don't know.
I got scared.
This is the unfinished basement.
Where does this go?
Oh, that goes to prison.
Can I go?
Yep.
And you just ran in.
No hesitation.
And you said I'm in.
That's prison.
And you sprinted.
Wait, why would I let you in?
I don't know.
Maybe I'm too...
I think I'm too, um, I'm too, um, I'm too, uh, Justice.
I have, I'm not, I'm not a criminal.
Okay, uh, Mint, so the problem is that the actual teleport
thing is one block up.
Since you're one block tall, you need to jump into it.
Okay.
Yeah,
wait, my head is.
Yeah.
Now we're in prison!
Prison!
Whoa!
What have you done?
They're so cute.
Oh!
What have you done?
I'm gonna shit.
Ah!
Do you think prison?
Woohoo!
Jail!
One for everybody so you can take everything inside.
How do I say anything?
Oh!
Yeah, like that.
So like, don't break these because everyone has their own.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh!
So like, you see stuff in there, you can take all of it
because that's only generated for you.
different in there oh that's crazy thank you Heidi yeah yeah
they're shared chests everything is shared what oh my god a
diamond yeah what's the axe you have uh my thunderbrand
thunderbrand this is where i found my my yeah i got it from
the prison one time armor and diamonds oh
it's so fun this is so cool it is Book.
I should take everything.
I need everything.
I'm broke.
You know it.
This place is so huge.
That's badass.
All I've gotten are like lame little assassin daggers from
the dungeons.
That sucks, dude.
You got Thunderbrand?
Yeah, I got Thunderbrand.
Oh, I got a weapon.
Yay!
Weapon?
Yeah.
Which one did you got?
The gold sigh.
Oh.
Nice!
Watch out, watch out, I'm a new...
What's that thing?
Oh, that's an enemy.
It is?
It's so...
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh my god.
The prisons are full of treasure, but they're also full of
enemies.
You gotta be careful.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is so fun.
Oh my god.
It's so cool But you can get a lot of really good things in
here Don't the prisons reset after a certain amount of time?
I don't know I don't know either But I just No I think this
is like a prison that's going I think you have to like
destroy your portal and redo it to get a different prison Oh
That's smart That's smart Joel gave me the portal and I was
like It's funny if I put it in my basement Yeah I was like
how did you get that?
Why do you have a portal?
Yeah Oh!
Uh-oh.
Well.
She died!
That's it for Ari.
We're never seeing her ever again.
Ah!
She's gone forever.
Ain't nothing you can do about that.
She's gone.
Oh, hi, Ari!
I woke up back!
You made it!
Right here!
I think there's a guy right behind me.
Oh, um...
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna skill issue you.
No!
Don't do it!
Don't do it with Thunderbrand!
It's so cool!
These kind of photo is everywhere you see it at the
outfield.
So when you find it, you can go inside and get the loot.
There's so many portal out there.
So they're all random?
Yeah, I will say there's like a boss in each prison.
I wouldn't attack the boss because when you attack it it
closes it off for everybody else oh okay okay go in the
prison anymore once the boss is meeting the boss before how
do you see him the prison i used to go to i think um
heavenly defeated the boss there and now i can't go in there
anymore oh oopsie yeah it's closed all oh no okay yeah why
would you do that to me heavenly oh wait maybe this one
The Zen raided me and I didn't notice for our...
Oh no!
Ann!
I'm so sorry, Zen!
The tea is ready.
Thank you, Zen!
I was so focused on the game!
Thank you for playing!
I hope you had a wonderful...
Finally!
Yes!
I am so sorry!
Finally!
I even forgot what's streaming!
Solity, Solity!
Thank you, Zed.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
Hello, Raiders.
Welcome.
We're playing Minecraft with Mint, Addy, Froggy, and Hanya,
and Neverbloody.
This is my first time Mint joining the server.
It's first time.
I hope you enjoy it.
Yeah, first time.
Her first time.
My first time.
Oh my gosh, it's so exciting.
Everything's new.
Just like me.
Look at this guy.
Can I take him home?
Oh, you can.
You can destroy him with a pickaxe.
I think it has to be a...
Is she talking about a corpse?
Nope.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Can I take this home?
You can.
You can take him home.
Hold on.
There you go.
Oh, there you go.
I think you know...
Oh, my God, I have him.
Why is one of the first things you want on the server a
corpse?
A tiny little skeleton.
Spooky scary skeleton.
Stivers up for spawn.
I like stealing these torches a lot of the time too.
Oh, they're really neat.
I like them.
Yeah, they're good torches.
Yeah.
Wow, I want to keep just exploring all the...
But this place is dangerous, right?
It is, but if you're with somebody that has a good weapon,
it's not too bad.
Yeah.
Yeah, unless you get the good weapon, it's not scary
anymore.
Yeah.
you can go down you can go under the prison and i haven't
been able to find it again like i found it just once this
hole that goes under the prison and i haven't been able to
find it no i swear it was this one i swear it was this one
i'm not lying it's your first time here what do you mean
it's your first time here how can i be lying what are you
saying got a big sword Wow, look at you!
You got a big sword!
Look at it!
I swear that was a little war.
Maybe I should get you a backpack.
Hold on.
A backpack?
I swear to God.
A backpack!
The audio crunches that?
The sound of players.
Uncrunch yourself.
Backpack.
How do I get the regular backpack?
Thank you guys.
Hold on.
I have a gift for you.
A gift?
Uh-huh.
If you give me a little bit of movement.
Okay.
I thought you were going to say give me a little bit of
movement.
little bit of money.
I'll pay you.
Where's your money, Daio?
Oh, here, here, here, here, here, here, here.
I have a gold de blune.
No, no, no, no.
It's yours.
Don't give it to me.
No, it's okay.
I'm paying you.
No, no.
It's your first day.
I'm going to give you a backpack that you will love it.
Okay.
Well, it looks so stylish.
Yeah, you.
You will!
And a leather...
A leather... What else do I need?
Yeah, first day is free.
For today?
For today, it's free, babe.
Yes.
How do I get sleep in that?
How do I get sleep in that chat?
Oh, okay, free wall.
Land cell?
It's a, I mean, it's kinda, but it's a backpack.
Look.
Look, look, look, yeah, yeah.
Look, yeah, yeah.
Wait, did you give it to me?
No, not yet.
I'm making one.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Here's your backpack.
Are you gonna give it to me?
Oh, there we go, there we go.
Wait, so how do I put it on?
Oh, so hold the backpack.
You click it and you should be able to see that there's an
icon that says like...
It tells you to wear it.
Oh!
Wait, how do I wear it?
Oh, I have to hold it in my hand.
The people stand.
Yeah, you have to hold it in your hand.
And when you click it, you see the icon, Steve standing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
And we can upgrade it so you can have more stuff inside.
I can upgrade it for you later.
Okay, wait.
Yeah.
Where does...
How do I open it now?
Where does it go?
You press B and then you open it.
B.
O.
V.
B.
And B.
I think my...
Beautiful B.
I think it's my...
My key binds are weird.
I'll do it later.
It's okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah.
Oh, it's still weird?
It's okay though.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, but it's so good, it's so good.
I want to find more treasure, Hanya.
Let's go find more treasure.
Oh, have you go up here?
Where?
Up here, you see this chain?
Oh!
Uh-oh.
What's up?
I thought I saw something.
No!
What's my achievement?
Oh, I collected loot.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Take it all.
Guts.
I like when they drop their body parts.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool.
Oh, my health.
You're right.
My health?
My health is bad.
Oh, your health?
Oh, do you need food?
Oh, I can't eat honeycomb.
Can I eat guts?
You can!
I'm eating them!
Yummy guts!
Yummy guts da yo!
Guts da yo!
Guts, oi!
Niku, niku.
Maybe.
Oh, there they are!
Hello?
Hi!
I'm eating really fast.
Killed by
a leaping zombie!
Um...
What's in here?
Nothing.
Oh, there's a...
Oh.
Why is it open like that?
So many of these things.
Oh!
Music.
Accept.
I'm back!
Welcome back!
It's okay.
It happens, you know.
It happens, it happens.
Yeah, no problem.
The problem, do you?
Oopsie.
Oopsie, daisy do you.
Yeah, oopsie, poopsie.
No problem.
Oopsie, poopsie.
More loot.
I like how the enemies didn't spawn until you guys came back
over.
They were just chilling, eating food, and then you came
they just all spawn we're just that popular you know they're
they're like genius gotta said my kamiyoshi oh yeah my
kamiyoshi and you're the genius oh uh-oh oh don't know me oh
nice oh another treasure chest over here oh oh diamond yeah
you get my diamond running out of base nice oh you want to
go back oh you gotta you gotta hit your chest what the is
that behind me oh my god you saved you saved my life save
your day oh what's it oh
she's got this she's gonna keep taking stuff she is build
different I'm just taking that one.
Oh, I know.
Go to the second floor.
It's okay, I got it.
Thank you!
Nice!
This one goes to deeper.
Deeper.
There's more floors.
Oh, I like the tapestry.
Oh, Froggy wasn't lying.
There is, there is.
She doesn't need to know that.
Sure.
I told you I wasn't lying!
I told you!
Oh, she's here!
Yeah!
I haven't explored yet, but there's...
It keeps going.
Oh!
No!
Froggy, no!
That was impressive.
That was fast.
That was, yeah, that was...
That was pretty quick.
I don't think Froggy suffered, you know.
It's good.
It's a quick death.
Also, I can make you a hook shot.
Hold on.
It's really handy when you don't have a Laytra.
Oh yeah.
I saw about giving you a Laytra.
If you want, I can give it to you.
But also I don't want to take away your experience too.
So let me know if you want.
Oh no, it's okay.
I'll go.
I'll get one myself.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, thank you though.
Of course!
Adi?
Sorry!
Too bad!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hangya!
If you swing on me, you swing on Mint!
Here you go, get her!
Get her hangya!
Sacrifice me!
Yeah!
Woohoo!
Wait, hold on, I'm gonna make you a hook shot.
Hold on.
Okay!
I'm trying to change my key bind still.
Key stone, key stone.
Hi!
You know, maybe I deserve that.
How's the taste of defeated, da yo?
Back in Pandora.
Yeah.
Don't you give me that sassy?
Yeah!
What is it?
I didn't care what?
Wait.
You're too sassy.
You're too sassy, Hanya.
It's sassy baka, da yo.
There we go.
I'm trying to give her to...
Oh!
Okay, I need arrow.
There we go.
Did you see that?
I'm built different.
Are you good?
I think I'm doing Gangnam Style right now.
Hey, sexy lady!
I did a flip even.
Oh my god.
Get it, man.
Get it.
Welcome back, Froggy.
Watch this.
Thank you.
Woo.
Hell yeah, brother.
I'm learning.
Oh, you're learning.
Oh, you found the email.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
That is my favorite thing.
Backflip.
Ah.
Oh my god, it's so fun.
The flip is so funny.
I give you a hook shot.
Oh, thank you.
Wait, I think I need more space.
Uh-oh.
Emo.
Uh.
Escape.
Maybe E.
Now B.
Oh, I did it.
I did it.
Okay, nice, nice.
Nice.
Yay.
Oh.
You can go up like this.
It's like a hook shot.
Okay.
Let me see.
There's so much space down here.
Where is it?
Oh, here it is.
There's so much space for activities.
Hey, Froggy.
You have an Electro.
Why did you just, why did you not just glide down?
I forgot.
Like this.
That's understandable, I guess.
I'm ordering food, okay?
My head is out.
Oh, I did it.
Wait, I just finished eating.
Wait, are you eating sometimes?
Yeah, just like that.
Okay.
Easy peasy.
Thank you.
Of course, of course!
Do you wanna put down some of your stuff because you tell me
that you're fooling now?
Oh, I have a backpack now, I'm okay.
Okay, okay.
Sorry, I have to pee.
Don't let me die.
Okay.
Okay, I have to pee.
Okay, go pee.
Diamond.
Peace.
Kella!
Yeah!
Take her down.
Oh no!
She's suffocating!
You didn't kill her.
She suffocated.
Yeah, that's a tragedy, Dale.
How'd that happen?
That's so weird.
Wow, wow.
I think it bugged.
Yeah, the bugged.
It's a weird glitch.
She's gonna see that she suffocated.
That's not possible.
Yeah, you need to.
Okay, there we go.
I think it's dead.
No!
Oh!
Oh.
You're so strong in there.
Thank you.
No one- You got the really good armor.
Yeah.
If it wasn't the consequences of my own actions.
Oh.
My hands were glitched so I couldn't switch to my weapon.
Uh-oh.
But I'm good now.
I can take him down.
Real good, real good.
Get him!
Oh, yeah, I was gonna die.
What's this?
I got a bugger.
Oh, experience nugget.
Ew!
I thought it was a bugger.
It was an experience nugget.
What is that?
Oh yeah!
You cloud and uh...
You can use it.
Nice!
Oh wait!
Yeah?
Here, I don't know if this is better than what you have, but
that's a really good sword.
Oh!
What is this?
Oh, thank you!
Oh my god, I've studied the blade.
Oh, you look cool!
I do.
She studied the blade.
You look like a Raiden, Raiden!
Raiden!
Yeah, I'm Raiden!
Yeah!
I'm looting everything me too oh I got him time
to let her rip and I did oh she keeps having to teleport me
one day I killed him I just also died at the same time you
know it's a little necessary sacrifice a counterproductive
maybe a little bit
oh no not that oh what's that oh sorry i actually charged up
oh oh it's me my my my thunderbrand it does like this thing
that's crazy yeah yeah i can like charge more than hurt
people
Anything in here?
Nope.
No treasure.
Sometimes it goes further down and sometimes it can bite it,
but I'm not sure about that.
Oh!
Nice kill!
Nice kill.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute, the little body.
I'm gonna take him home.
Oh, you want him?
Yeah, I want this guy.
Is it okay?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah!
Zayn?
There we go.
Thank you!
Zayn!
Hi, Zayn.
Oh.
She immediately died.
Kale.
Is she- I should have...
Da-Yon!
.
Zen here!
Why is my chat telling me to run?
Uh oh.
She got on, die, and left.
Never mind.
I guess we're safe, everybody.
Good job, Zen.
Alright.
I'm gonna go this way.
Yeah.
I'm following you guys, because I'm weak.
Nice kill!
I'm about to die.
No!
Yeah!
Nice, nice!
Treasure!
I'm getting so many chains.
Yeah, me too.
You can't hit me!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
There's so many chests.
Oh!
That sounded close.
Yeah, I have one heart left, so I'm just like...
Do you need some flash?
I have some guts for you.
You can eat guts?
Yeah!
They're delicious.
Yeah, you can eat it.
You can eat it.
Oh, that is back.
I got a nutcracker.
A nutcracker, nice!
Oh.
I have a food, so I can give you guys if you want to.
What does this do?
It deals critical damage to frozen and stunned enemies.
Ah!
Cool.
Nice, nice.
What's a runic tablet?
I never used it before.
I think it's for fixing weapons?
I think?
Time to break some nuts.
Yay!
Yeah!
I took it.
Oh, you took it?
I can put it.
Here we go.
Oh, thank you.
Right here.
Thank you very much.
Yeah!
Not a thing.
I love how...
Every time I get on Minecraft, I do everything but the thing
I got on Minecraft do.
That's how it goes, isn't it?
Oh my gosh, with this I'm gonna be exploring forever though.
I'm gonna...
Oh, I know the dungeons.
Yeah, I'm gonna be going through the dungeons forever.
Stealing all the bodies.
There are like so many things to do in this game.
It's a lot.
Oh no, I broke him!
Oh, maybe it has to be a silk touch.
I think so.
It has to be silk touch to take the bodies.
Oh no.
That's okay.
I have silk touch.
I think I only need one stinky man.
Oh, one thing.
Why not two stinky men or three stinky men?
You know what?
You're so right.
Why not have more stinky men?
Yeah, only so the extra stinky.
I made one request of you.
me even now you're letting me die even now you're letting me
shoot me in the brain oopsie i totally forgot a lot has
happened what does this do so much so much happened oh i see
i see okay yeah you got caught up you got caught up yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever you say yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh Oh, oh.
I think we're okay.
Oh, oh.
Oh, thank you!
Thank you, Anu!
Yeah!
Guys.
Anytime.
We know you can get the cardboard!
Why is it cool down?
Just like a half-life!
What?
Where do I get this from?
From even?
No!
Uh-oh.
Oh.
You're not protecting me?
Am I supposed to?
Yep.
Oh, you came back so I didn't think that was my job anymore.
Lynn, I found your stinky guy.
You did!
Yeah!
You want him?
Let's see.
Whoa!
Yeah, I'll take him.
I'll take him.
There you go.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Now I have a corpse.
I have a rotting corpse.
I have a skeleton.
I have all three phases.
You got all phases.
Yeah!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
This is so exciting.
I know.
It's a lot of stuff.
Oh, you gotta find a place to build your house, too.
Yeah.
Well, you're right.
There are so many places.
Yeah, they're hard in so many biomes.
Let's put this up here.
Oh, thanks, guys.
Okay.
Let's see if I'm gonna go.
The only thing I would suggest is not building near the
spawn because it gets a little laggy.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I will not do that.
Mike,
Chad, I love we still exploring a froggy's house.
That's true!
We're still in the froggy's house.
You're right!
Oh my god, technically, yeah.
The frog's dungeon.
Yeah, there's just the biggest house.
So many rooms.
She got the biggest house.
I didn't know you had a big basement or prison.
Yeah.
This is where my mods live.
Why does mom let you have a basement?
Your mods live in a basement too?
Mine too!
Oh no.
I'm taking care of you guys.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh,
okay.
I'm okay.
Oh!
I can handle myself.
Yeah.
But I couldn't find the boss.
Uh-huh.
Maybe you have to summon him with the item.
Where are you guys?
How did she die?
I'm behind you.
You're behind me?
Hi.
Hello.
Can you get armor in the chests?
No.
Wait, can we?
I only find a weapon but not an armor.
Yeah.
Maybe it's not possible.
Oh.
Yeah.
That I spawned in Zen's bed and Zen was there and I was like
Zen and she logged out
He just she just abandoned me I don't know Here I go Oh,
there I go There I go Oh Thank
you, I'm not sure Of course anytime I think it's for the
boss want to go i just hear the distance there the balls oh
yummy oh i need some guts too yummy yummy yummy guts
delicious i think i'm becoming a zombie a little bit maybe a
little bit that's a little concerning no it's okay it's okay
i seek the highest quality of guts
It's gotcha da yo.
It's gotcha da ze.
Oh, da ze?
Whoa, it's upgraded.
There's a song in Japan that is called like gotcha da ze,
you know, and stuff like that.
Oh, really?
I think it's like a very old song.
It takes you to like this forest.
Oh.
Yeah, it takes you to a forest with a bunch of nice trees.
Ooh.
There's even a cage.
Yeah.
You should take it.
Come here!
Yeah!
Can I...
Okay, trap...
Oh!
Oopsie.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I think I'm obsessed.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I think I'm obsessed with the mines.
Not the mines.
The dungeons.
Oh my god, I will never leave the dungeons.
Ouch.
Wait, what's this over here?
Oh, they're all a bunch of pigs!
Oh, so I saw him with somebody's birthday.
Uh, Dissecrator!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, it's hard to reach out when, um...
When, when it's a collab.
But thank you guys, thank you!
Hello!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Oh!
Nice.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there's two in here.
More guts.
More guts in book and iron.
yeah in this
what did you do for that how do you know what the oh I see
what a capacity a penta condor oh
what's this there's so much here wait hold on this one's
kind of funny I just found a weapon and it's like this big
like hammer thing and it's called nutcracker that's what I
got earlier yeah no oh my god look at him oh no I kind of
want to take him home oh I can take you I can break it for
you wait wait what was the first one in you I can take I can
take him I can take him home yeah oh did you get Oh, thank
you!
Of course!
Do the skeletons stack?
Oh my gosh, they do!
I could take home so many skeletons!
You could take home so many.
I'm gonna have a whole room of skeletons.
Nice.
Oh, so there's some guts.
He gave you some guts.
For guts to eat.
Eat, is it?
Oh!
Hey, don't yuck our yum, okay?
Don't... don't...
You know...
My bad, my bad.
It's delicious.
Yeah, you gotta try it.
I say that but I'm also eating the guts.
I'm just trying not to think about it.
Don't knock it till you try it.
Wait.
Treasure, more treasure over here.
Is it this way that I haven't been?
How much treasure everywhere?
This way, this way.
Oh, this way.
There's more of them.
There's so much treasure.
I know, I know.
This is all you get, the good stuff.
Nice.
Oh.
You can see where I found thunder.
Ow!
Oh, really?
Yeah, isn't a dungeon like this?
I guess I just got really lucky.
You found what?
My weapon, Thunderbrand.
It's a really strong weapon.
Oh!
Thunderbrand, though.
So it's a gotcha.
Oh, what's this?
Yeah, it's kind of like a gotcha every time.
Oh, crowbar.
Yeah, you need a crowbar just like in the life...
Half-life.
Half-life!
Morgan Freeman!
Oh, watch out!
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I
died too.
I wonder where I should build my house.
I wonder where I should build it.
And you know who's Black Mesa now?
Finally.
Morgan Freeman, Morgan Freeman, Morgan Freeman.
I think that taught me really, really well, isn't it?
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Born to SAS people.
SOS Dayup.
What's so?
Suss.
Are you being suss, Hena?
No, she's being suss.
No, I'm being suss.
No.
Sassy.
Sassy or sassy?
What's the difference?
When you're like, when you're like, skillish, you die, when
you're mocking me, that's being sassy, Hena.
No, you die, no, you die.
No, you'd be genius.
I have to believe.
Geniuses are often sassy, you know.
Let's see Is it inventory full?
No, it's okay though.
I got lots of room still.
Nice, nice.
Yeah, I'm ready to keep collecting.
I think you were almost done in this floor?
Yeah.
I think we went everywhere.
I think so too.
Is there a chest?
Have we gone all the way down here?
Oh, I don't know.
What's so?
Which way?
We went that way.
This way.
We came from this way.
Yeah, so then have we gone all the way over here then?
Back here?
Yeah.
Because this part isn't even on the map.
Yeah, you're right.
Well, I haven't gotten this one.
Oh, me neither.
That's why we double check.
Yeah, I think we have.
I think we have.
Hmm.
Going this way.
This way.
Outer heaven.
Well, I think I've gone this way.
I think this is where I just was.
Apparently this mod is inspired by the game.
It's called Dead Cell?
Oh!
It didn't look like that.
I got...
Thank you.
I thought I was a goner.
I think we've been everywhere.
Yeah, I think so, I think so.
Oh, another broadsword.
Hmm.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, God.
Zelda is universal.
I love Zelda.
Power two.
Blah.
Guts.
Oh, I didn't open this one.
More guts.
Guts are a balanced, well-balanced breakfast.
I think that's it for Froggy's basement tour.
Yeah, I think so too.
Oh, hi Matara!
You guys haven't even seen Va.
Oh, is it Matara here?
Yeah, she's in my chat.
She's calling me a freak.
What?
She's calling you a freak.
Yeah, I don't know why.
Why am I a freak?
Mana!
Are you talking about my present from Hanya?
It's my very precious presents.
Yeah, precious things.
Yeah, I want to place it in her house.
Lakara Khan!
A freak.
I am a freaky ghostman.
Can we go back to spawn and see other stuff?
Yeah, I guess so.
Look around other stuff?
And spawn time.
Spawn.
To the spawn.
Oh.
Spawn.
We definitely just abandoned Froggy in there.
Oh, you're right.
That'll be fine.
It's probably okay.
What is this?
Yeah, she got this.
She'll be fine.
That.
Where else should we go?
Oh, I see, uh, the gun run in the sky is gone.
There was a gun run in the sky.
Wait, there was a giant painting of gun run in the sky.
Wait, why did it get rid of it?
I don't know.
I got on the other day.
There's these ones.
I wanted to see it.
That's so perfect.
They're really curves.
Oh, those are so cute.
These ones are so cursed.
Oh, oh,
yeah, there's...
These one...
These beautiful portraits.
Who made it?
It's genius, Kaya.
Those are perfect.
I love those.
I love it, too.
The eyes are so scary.
Oh, my God.
I got rid of the Gundam sun in the sky because it was a
lagging.
Oh!
Oh, I beat it.
The Piggy's turn.
Oh!
What happened?
Now should I run?
She just... What just happened?
Right click the button.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Emergency!
Hold on, Zen is up there.
Oh, Zen is God.
Oh, what's this?
It's inventory, isn't it?
There's loot here.
Oh, yeah?
Where is Zen?
Oh, there she is.
She left the game.
Oh, she left again?
Zen!
I was trying to say Zen!
She left the game.
I was going to find Minutaur.
You intimidated her.
Was my genius power.
Do you have any idea that you want to build a house on or
something?
I don't know where, yeah.
I'll find somewhere.
Maybe.
You want to see other people's house?
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh, I want to show you the, um, Amuchi place, so hold on.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, Michi's place is so nice.
Wait!
Oh, you're on my head?
Okay.
Wait!
Oh, I had you!
Oh.
Maybe this.
Um.
going on my own hello I think I'm here I don't I don't know
I don't know what she got up there wait what do you mean
you're on my head I am wait no you're on my head no I'm on
nobody's head you're on my head no she's on she's on head
you but she's also on my head i don't see i see myself do
you see me walking on the ground no i see you on my head uh
let me leave the server and i'll come back okay okay what is
going on i think the game is bugged did you see my home yet
it's a hole in the ground no i haven't going on my own a
tour in Japan in a week.
Any recommendations?
Maid's Cafe!
Here we go.
What am I wearing?
Oh.
Thank you.
Am I normal again?
Yeah, you're normal.
Yeah, you are.
This is a good place.
Oh, the chimes are so cool.
They are.
They make a good sound.
She also made this, like, a farm for the wool as well.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your farming methods are so cute.
It is.
I know, right?
It looks so adorable.
Wait, how does it farm?
Oh, I think there's, like, scissor inside and sheer sheer
inside.
Oh, I see it.
But I think it's not working because the shoes are broken.
Oh, it's down here!
It's all working, I think.
Oh, it's this snail thing again.
Oh, oh god!
Oh, my god.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Mmm.
And this is her room.
Right here.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh, she also has dead people.
Oh?
Maybe I should add.
Here.
Rod and corpse.
Corpse.
Oh.
Skelly man.
Corpse, corpse, skeleton man.
I like the skeleton.
I do too.
He's really cute.
I like it.
Also, when you put the The corpse on the ground, it makes
the mushy sound like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa, wait, whose house is this?
This is roots.
Oh, okay, okay.
Whoa, there's a piggy head too.
Yeah!
They are, they are.
Ah!
I knew you were gonna do that.
I'm safe!
Yeah!
I'll go around.
I'll go down.
Here we go.
There we go.
What is this?
Is there anything down here?
Oh wait, there is some stuff down here.
Oh, wait a minute.
This is where the treasure at, wasn't it?
Treasure?
More treasure?
Oh, what is that?
I think there's a treasure around here.
You're Good?
Yep, I'm okay!
Oh, there's a treasure, there's a treasure!
Oh, oh, oh, zombie.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, there's a lot of stuff in here.
Woo!
Wait, is this the same where it's different for everybody?
It's different for everybody, so you can take it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Except the regular chest, you can take everything inside.
Oh, nice!
Wow.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, I'm actually gonna run out of space.
Tomato seeds!
Can you add the mimics to this?
They used to have a mimics, but I don't know, maybe it was
lagging the server.
It's good now.
What's a mimic?
Oh, like it would eat the, it would eat you.
Yeah, it's like a freedom, but it's gone now.
Aw, man.
No!
Freyren, some more.
Oh wait.
Take these.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I think that's the treasure.
I'm about to tell you important things.
Yeah.
Do you remember the place that we changed the heights?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There is a green portal and when you go there, it leads to
like a mirror world from this one.
Oh.
That one is for like resource.
So when you get a lot of wood, when you want to get a little
wood or dirt or stuff like that, you can get it from there.
Oh, that's so awesome!
Yeah!
So you don't take everything from this world.
Oh!
Like if you want to keep the landscape, but you want to get
a lot of material in your world, I didn't get the oldest
stuff you need.
That's so smart!
That's so awesome!
Oh my god.
And yeah, this place is amazing.
It is!
It was my first time modding Minecraft as well, but I love
it so much.
Yeah!
I could say why.
I love it.
I think Zen is having connection problems.
Oh, no.
Yeah, I ran up to her when she was on, and she had, like,
that disconnect symbol next to her, and I think that's why
she keeps logging in and logging out.
Ah.
Oh.
Yeah, she's got connection problems, I think.
Oh, I wonder why is that happening to her?
I don't know.
No, I wish I could join her and join us.
Yeah.
That happened to Heavenly too?
Oh, no.
Yeah, Heavenly can't get on anymore.
Oh, really?
Really?
Oh.
All right, Zen!
Um...
Man!
I think...
Maybe Zen is fine.
I think she's fine.
Yeah.
You have to disconnect this.
I worried for no reason.
What's that?
Oh, it's that guy again.
What does this thing do?
What does he do this guy?
When you find him for like three times, after you find him,
he'll be gone.
And after you find him for three times, he'll give you a
gift.
Oh!
Oh, that's that one guy.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Was it his name?
It was Russell or something?
Oh, there he is!
Oh!
Oh, he's escaping!
He's climbing up!
No, sir!
Oh, sir!
Okay, okay, he's gone again.
We gotta go find him.
But that was the third time!
Sir, sir, or fourth?
I forgot, but you have to find him for multiple times.
Okay.
You'll hear him before- Oh, I see him, I see him!
Oh, do you do?
Right here.
Wow!
Oh!
He gave?
Something.
There you go, there you go.
What was it?
Take it, take it.
A bundle.
Oh!
Oh, there's a gold blocks in it.
Where did I go?
Oh.
I need this one.
Do you want your potatoes back?
Oh, is it your magnet, Henya?
No, no, it's okay.
I have a lot of potato.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm going to put the mailbox.
Wait, how do I put the mailbox?
Oh, there we go.
Hmm.
Nice.
Cool!
Yeah!
What a cool guy.
Hard to combat roll forward.
Yeah, he just kind of shows up randomly.
He really likes Mata's dirt household.
Oh wait, I heard about that.
Yeah, he shows up there a lot.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
I wonder why.
Mata, you have someone living in your house.
Oh my gosh, she scared me.
Yeah, someone taking over.
over your house, Mata.
Yeah.
Should come back and claim it.
How do we get out of here?
Oh, wait, they're here.
Oh, we go up here.
That's right.
Yeah.
Oh, I can't see.
Oh, I don't know how I'm climbing.
I don't know how I'm climbing, but I'm climbing.
I don't know how this is happening.
Oh, God.
Oh, there we go.
I don't know how that happened.
Careful, careful.
Oh.
Are you okay?
Did Henya just fall?
What a thrill.
I think Henya just fell.
Has Henya met Henya Junior yet?
Wait, what is Henya Junior?
Henya Junior.
What is a Henya Junior dial?
What is that?
What?
I have a Henya Junior?
Would you like your corpses back, Mint?
Yeah, I think I missed them.
He needs your corpses back.
I can do it for you.
Thank you.
Oh.
I think you like them more than I do.
Here, I'll stand really close.
I think you...
Here you go.
Oh.
Thank you!
Something must be sacrificed.
I'll sacrifice this dagger.
Oh.
Oh, you know what?
You have a trash can at the bottom.
So if you put your item, you don't need it.
over there oh yeah what and then it's gone forever yeah yeah
it'll be gone forever you can like get it back out as long
as you don't put something else in the trash can oh but if
you put something else in there then it's gone that's crazy
yeah bing bong bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing just
keep adding stuff to it i don't know what else to add i need
everything else everything else is precious
cool we got so many stuff over here
Everybody's leaving!
What's happening?
Is there a bee in here?
Oh, it's a bee lamp!
That's so cute!
Yeah!
I can make you one if you want to.
But the...
So, sometimes you might will get some item you don't know
how to use it.
Yeah.
And then when you go to the...
I'm also like pointing at the item you don't know how to use
it and press U.
It'll show you the recipe and what can you do with it.
Oh really?
Wait you press what?
U.
Yeah!
Whoa.
U.
You.
Whoa!
So you can see it with U.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh my god, there's so much!
There is, there is!
Ooh, witch's house.
This is so cute!
It is!
Oh, do you want to go to N-City?
You want to touch like a waystone so you can go back anytime
you want?
Oh, sure!
Okay.
There we go.
Oh,
she left us, everybody.
Now, we're just out here.
And then, oh, gloomy bear.
There's a big old gloomy bear.
There's this house over here.
Oh, there's a way to stone here.
This is the kitten hole.
This...
She hates us.
She hates us!
What?
Huh?
Oh!
What?
Who hates you!
No, no, oh, oh, oh, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no But it's a different.
Let's see.
Anything.
Oh, wait.
There's trees in here.
There's trees.
And Midlands.
What's this?
This is a special kind of tree.
Prem log.
Oh, no.
Everybody keeps crashing.
Is it me?
Am I the problem?
Hi, y'all.
Welcome back.
Did it crash for you too?
Oh, why are we in the end?
Oh, because I thought she was my favorite Elitra.
Oh.
So much happened.
Ah!
It fired me!
What's wrong with him?
Why is he among us?
Man.
So I think, I think the problem is, is Zen's house, because
I crashed too when I went near Zen's house.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, really?
We went with no problems though.
Yeah, the first time I went was no problems, but then when I
went again, what happened to the armor I gave you?
It broke because everybody kills me every five seconds.
No!
I have no more armor because everything, everything breaks.
Sad that you have no armor.
Everybody kills me every five seconds.
I'm trying to not make eye contact with any of these
enemies, but because I know I shouldn't look at them, I want
to look at them.
I know.
Oh wait, hold on.
This is not the end zone that I was trying to take her with.
Hold on.
Oh, it's different?
Where's she go?
Oh, that guy...
I don't know.
That guy, why is...
I'm gone.
She left us.
There's like some weird endermans that look like among us.
What?
That guy right there.
Oh!
Oh yeah, he just...
He attacks on...
Like, he doesn't...
You don't need to look at him for him to attack if he just
sees you.
He'll attack you.
Oh!
Oh, I think we should go.
Oh, oh, thank you.
So if you ever want to go to the Duffy Ender Dragon and
stuff, it's right here.
Oh, oh, that's an annoying thing.
Not friend.
Where's the...
Where's...
Oh, Hania!
Hania!
Hold on, come here, Hania.
Hania, jump, Hania.
Oh, no.
Uh, how do I pick you guys up?
Uh, help!
Good luck!
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah, you're on my head.
You're on my head now.
How do I get Henny off my head?
Wait, I'm not.
You're on my head for me.
It's okay, I'll just keep you on my head.
Wait, I don't see you on her head either.
Yeah, I'm not.
You are for me.
What?
It's okay, I'll just have a pet.
The server's having a little bit of trouble, I think.
Yeah, it's a little laggy today.
Wait, is there a waste stone here or?
Oh, this way, this way.
This way?
I don't know where this one is.
Right here.
And you're still on my head.
Oh!
Wait, where?
Oh, right here, right here.
Oh, I see it.
It blended in.
Nice.
And portal dial.
Whoa, it's so cool in here too.
Yeah, but it looks a lot different as well.
Yeah, it looks so different.
Oh, I...
Monster Hunter.
I can't.
Mon-Han, Mon-Han.
Mon-Han.
Wait, you play Mo-Han?
No, but right now, actually, there's a sale on a bunch of
Mon-Han games.
I want to get them.
I'm playing World right now, so if you ever want to play it
with me, I'm always available.
Okay, that fixed it.
That fixed it.
You got it?
Oh, welcome back, Adi.
Yeah, yeah, I logged out and logged back in so I could fix
it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Mermaid.
Oh yeah!
Wait!
These are like rainbow candles.
They're cute!
They're really cute!
It is pretty!
Yeah.
I want to steal them.
Do it.
Steal it.
No one can stop me.
Oh!
There's a lot.
There's a lot of places to explore.
If you ever want to, you can.
Named.
So many name tags.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Wow.
I'm out of space.
I think we should get the good backpack for you.
I'm gonna get it.
It's okay.
Mouse can help you?
For a prize.
I can get her.
It's okay.
I don't really care about my soul.
Hold on.
Do I have it?
Do they stack?
This...
Man, where was the Henya Lone Shark hospitality for me, huh?
What do you mean, Daya?
What do you mean?
I'm a generous, Daya.
Anya, you've been an amazing tour guide.
You've been so nice.
So everything.
Yeah.
You stole my candles.
Anya?
No!
See, this is what I mean!
She's over here!
Everything comes with a price, Adi.
Yep.
Nothing is free, Daya.
Nothing is free.
you.
It's okay, Hanya, if you need a henchman for your business,
I'm here for you.
Thank you, did my business.
Hanya, I built a watermelon for you.
That is true.
It took you seven hours, he said.
It took me seven hours.
No way.
Oh, wait, have you shown her?
Oh, yeah, I did.
Remember the Colonel's plays watermelon?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the watermelon.
Oh, my God.
It's a watermelon.
took a long time yeah very long time super long we also made
a wall for the mochi house too you want to see it oh yeah
let's go spawn spawn oh okay so this way this way
What is the Henya Junior?
Okay, I need to see the Henya Junior.
When the heck did I get the Henya Junior, Deo?
Oh, so cute!
Yeah, her place is so cute!
Let's see.
She stole the dirt from my chest, so I gave her the wall of
dirt.
You need a square dirt over there, I gave her a wall of
Oh, I see it!
Yeah!
Up there, that wall?
Yeah, the huge, yeah.
Wow.
I and I and Mouth did it together.
Her place is so fun.
When you go down here...
This way, this way.
This way, this way, this way.
This way, okay.
There's a...
There's a toilet.
But you can go in.
Oh.
But they're revving up to use the toilet.
Is that what's going?
Yeah, I'm wrapping up to use the toilet.
It's okay, I get it.
We all have a little bit of something to get rid of, get out
of there, you know?
Why is the gun run on the ceiling?
Oh.
Yeah, there's a gun on the ceiling.
Can you see it?
Yeah, I see him.
Oh!
It's the Hanya.
Hanya, you had one job.
No, no, it's not me.
I think emoji did it.
Mochi did it.
I wonder.
Did you just say dang it?
What did I hear from you?
No, no, no, no.
I think Mochi is somewhere.
Well, yeah, yeah.
Do you think she's like maybe she's invisible?
She pulled the lever?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pretty sure she did it.
I'm pretty sure she's the one who did it.
I don't see her on the server.
I don't see her.
Oh, hold on.
I think one is so cute though.
They have legs?
What else is in here?
I don't know, her place is like a lot of, you can go a lot
of places.
I like the fish tanks.
Oh!
I thought this was a person.
She has security cameras and everything!
Yeah!
I'm gonna give her something.
A lot of security camera over here.
Yeah.
How should I give her?
No, I want my room.
You know what?
I'll keep everything.
Ew, they walk.
That's a hair brine again!
Why there's a hair brine everywhere?
Up there too!
Oh my gosh!
You've had another one?
That's terrifying!
I found another one right there!
I've been jump scared by so many of those.
There's so many of them!
Oh, I see it right there!
Oh my gosh, it's kind of...
It's really realistic looking.
It's in here too!
Do you see him?
Oh my god.
Where?
Right here.
Over here, right?
Right here, right here.
No, no, no, right here.
Right here.
I look that way.
I see him.
Right in the... on the wall, right?
Uh...
I think you're looking at a different direction.
There's more...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I see him!
Whoa!
Scary though.
Why you can't see in here?
I think this is her mining area, I think?
I don't know.
Maybe, yeah.
Hmm.
Can't see how anywhere in here.
Everything is...
Oh, I'm lost.
Oh, water.
I'm just going to drop down.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, oh, it's all...
Oh, she has a limpet too.
Oh, yeah, she has a limpet too.
It's a quest.
What's this?
She got a lot of stuff.
Yeah, fish tank.
Wait, I don't see Henia Jr. Where is that?
Prismarite.
Yeah, where's Henia Jr.?
Wait!
Four skins?
Four skins skin.
Henia Jr.?
Four skin Jr. So many, so many.
There's just so many.
And she got Mei-chan over here.
Okay.
Why are there so much- She got the hidden junior at the
dome?
Is this it?
No, fourth.
This way.
Up here.
She got the beautiful dorm as well.
What is it?
No, not this way.
This is definitely a meechy place, yeah.
I think so too.
She also is a little man.
Wow!
Look at it!
Oh my goodness!
This table is so good!
The axolotls are all so many different colors.
Who is that?
Who is that, you guys?
It's Kuro?
No!
It's mint!
It's Kuro!
What?
Wait, who's that?
Oh, what's gun run?
Oh my god, these are alive!
Oh my god.
Haruka Jr. Uh...
Adi Jr., Fruit Jr., Kuro Jr., Giga Jr., Matan Jr. Dusclamp
Jr. Iron Mouse Jr. Heavenly Jr. Sushi Jr. Joel Jr. Mm-hmm.
Is there... is there Hanya Jr. maybe in here?
Maybe in here?
Hanya Jr. Oh no, it's just Hanya!
Hanya Jr. Right here, right here.
Where's... where's my junior?
He's right...
here.
If you look...
Here, here, here.
Right there, right there.
Hanya Jr. Hanya Jr. Hanya Jr. Did I hear that?
So... Oh.
Oh, did you eat yourself?
No, no, of course not.
Of course not.
I will never.
No.
Oh, is that Jerma?
Gingerbread picnic.
Please don't eat it.
Is this Jerma?
You can eat them?
Thank goodness I didn't eat them.
That's Linus.
Oh.
They're in the picnic?
That's so cute.
Is Jerma...
At the other side?
What's this?
Jerma?
Yeah, I think he's on the wall.
Oh, really?
Yeah, right here.
Wait, that's a Jerma song?
I think so.
Oh, everybody talking about him, but I never know what does
he look like.
Yeah!
I see him?
Jerma song!
Jerma?
No, you know.
No, it's a different people.
What is this?
That's not Jerma.
I will never know what Jerma-san look like.
Maybe it's this one over here.
They say it's Kuro though.
Oh yeah, my chat told me that's Kuro.
It's his brother?
Wait, really?
Oh, he says brother?
That's wonderful.
He's so popular.
Nice.
Jiren Masan.
People keep talking about Jiren Masan.
One day I'll see him.
One day.
One day, one day.
He has a brother?
That's cool.
His gingerbread is so cute!
Yeah!
Oh, is this the room?
Oh.
Who is this?
It's a dog.
I love her kitchen.
That looks so cute.
This is kind of crazy.
It's kind of crazy.
Crazy.
I like it.
Wow.
Are you okay?
What the heck?
Oh!
Oh.
Why did so many guns come here?
I think she's obsessed.
I think so.
See you, hello.
Hi, Bousa.
No, she keeps the fox in a cage.
What is this?
The turtle?
I don't know.
What is that?
I don't think he's a turtle.
A dinosaur?
A little dinosaur?
Little baby dinosaur.
A little baby dinosaur trapped in here, do you?
So sad.
That's abuse.
I'm reporting her.
Oh, and a smoking bird.
Yeah, she got the smoking bird.
What?
It's not good for you.
Don't smoke.
That's why Robin is dying.
Stop smoking.
Yeah.
Stop dying smoking.
Smoking hot bird?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know about that.
I don't know about that, do you?
Stevie, hot kiddo in your area, do you?
Whoa.
Oh, starting to lag a little bit.
Oh, it's okay.
This was so fun, Henya.
Yeah, I hope you enjoy it.
I hope you enjoy it.
There's a lot of places that you can enjoy here.
So I really hope we can have fun together again soon.
Yeah, I will have to find a place to make my home.
Oh, yeah.
Do you have any places you want to make it?
I don't know.
Maybe next to your house.
Maybe under your house, above your house, in your house.
Oh, do you want to see what's under my house?
Yeah.
Okay.
You'll see it then.
I'm going to make you TP so it in the...
Okay, okay.
There she goes.
I'm going to make a house inside her house, under her house,
above her house.
Let's accept.
Welcome to my basement.
Wow, it's huge!
Yeah, I'm gonna place, I'm gonna place a lot of chest down
here so I can place everything I want.
Oh yeah, you already started!
Yeah!
I am, I am!
This is the inventory, oh this is the same thing Mousy had.
It's the same one!
I believe.
I need to place more.
Zen is coming here!
Zen!
I tried to steal my stuff again.
Oh, oh.
We're so fast.
Did she run away?
Did she steal my stuff?
Manga.
What's this?
But yeah, once you have a chest down here and you connect
with those, like, a cable, and this one the connector in the
terminal and you're ready to go oh yeah it's like moving
whoa whoa you have so many sticks I do I do whoa okay I'm
gonna learn from you I'm gonna build a huge place that's
gonna have every inventory item ever if you ever have a
question about the Minecraft I'll help you as I can.
Okay!
Thank you!
Of course!
Of course anytime!
I'm not gonna take anything.
Oh, thank you because everybody who took my stuff ended up
dead.
Oh.
By your hands or...
I don't know.
It just happens.
I'm not gonna take anything.
I don't want to end up dead by uh by Henya killing me who
would want that hmm yeah you're not stealing anything right
no no no no I'm looking at all the things that that the game
has to offer yeah yeah yeah I'm not taking a single thing
chat is she stealing my stuff no no no you were such a nice
you were such a nice tour guide why would I steal anything
yeah Yeah.
Stop touching!
AHHHHH!
No way!
Oh, I'm out of the way back here!
Oh my god, I forgot that I set my spawn point.
Spawn.
Is he at the end point?
I'm here!
Oh, welcome back!
Welcome back, Daya!
Thank you!
Here, I'll give you your egg back.
Thank you for the egg Thank you for the egg No happy
birthday None No life I also have like a Well I think a lot
of people took it So you can take an iron chest If you want
to Iron armor Oh thank you I might take it But also Mousy
gave me a lot of diamond I think I'll make diamond armor Oh
that's true That's true Mm-hmm I'll be more powerful.
There's a lot of places and a lot of people in here.
I hope you'll enjoy it.
Yeah, thank you, Hanya.
Thank you for giving me the tour today.
Of course!
Anytime, anytime.
Yeah.
I would love to play Minecraft with you more because always
I wanted to.
Yeah!
Okay.
I'll find a place to build and I'll play.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah!
Thank you.
And can you get it?
Please let me know.
Okay.
I for a prize, right?
Oh, no, not for me.
Not for me.
Really?
Yeah!
I wish I could crouch right now.
Oh, here, I can do this.
Oh, Henya Sama!
Henya Sama!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
No, no, no, no.
Yes!
Oh, so... so...
Tensai, so, so beautiful, so, so, subarashi.
Well, if you're asking, I can give you anything, but if you
steal, I'm going to give it.
Yeah!
Okay, I won't steal.
Yeah, no steal, no steal.
No steal.
When you do, when you do, something will happen, da yo.
That sounds horrible.
Something will happen, da, yo.
Like, I don't see, I don't wish that upon anybody.
Yeah.
Why would you steal?
Just ask her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm going to go talk to my chat now, Hanya.
Okay, thank you for hanging out with me.
Thank you.
Okay, I'll see you later.
I'll see you later too.
Bye-bye.
Bye!
Bye bye!
Oh, let me... I forgot to say by the mousy.
Let me go say bye to mousy.
And Zen too.
One second.
Oh.
Bye mousy.
Thank you.
Bye.
Zen.
a mouse is is is afk but maybe she'll see it and we could
steal stuff all right oh my gosh that sounds awesome if i
steal something she'll she'll ruin my life oh yeah baby that
sounds like the best thing ever you got braver with your
mask it's because she couldn't see my
Why does this fit on my head so well?
Why does this fit on my head actually so well, so perfectly?
Oh, well, maybe not perfect, perfect.
But it feels like my head was made to wear panties.
There we go.
Oh, I just needed to make it a little bit smaller.
Perfect.
Your head is the size.
eyes of Henya's butt.
Dang, she's got a big butt.
So I guess I have to find a place to build a house in there.
Oh gosh, there's so many... Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm a little... It's a little wobbly.
There's so many people that joined the server.
I've never met Ari before, Froggy before, but they were so
nice and I'm nervous about meeting new people, but I will do
my best to be so I'll do my best.
You can't believe you're wearing Henya's panties.
She gave them to me for this purpose.
You can take that mask off now.
The rest of the team can't see.
What do you mean, the team?
It was hot in there.
Thanks for the guide.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I think also the...
um what's it called all the mods i i i there's so much to
like be able to ah it's a pervert um there's so much to
there's so much to create show joe server was amazing modern
minecraft is completely different by the way nice hentai
common cosplay thank you mint what are your thoughts on dog
dog oh no don't get me started dog dog don't get me started
about saying dog dog because once i start saying dog dog i
won't stop saying dog dog over and i just gotta be able
compelled to say dog dog if i don't stop saying if i start
saying dog dog it can't stop saying dog dog i just gotta
keep saying dog dog i still prefer vanilla minecraft i think
both have its good things right because um because uh i
think i think the one thing if i could turn it off about the
vshojo server while but you know once dying and losing your
stuff is part of the thrill you know so it's part of the
thrill but but you know if if I if I I think for this it
seems very much more like like what's the word build
building stuff because there's so many pretty mods to like
customize your house and things like that they kill each
other a lot that makes sense too then you know it's also
what makes new players quit often i guess if you join a
server and uh and people are always there's a lot of pvp
then you know oh there were so many graves i believe it but
that was so fun oh i turned off my music earlier
I hope you guys enjoyed the tour as well.
Henya was so awesome for giving us such a nice tour.
And I hope you guys liked it.
Oh, there's a raid, but I can't read it.
Oh, my God.
I can't.
I can't read it.
Oh, I can't read it.
I'm so sorry, but thank you for the raid.
Oh.
Not to mention booby traps.
yeah the white on white is so bad it is salvi salvi thank
you thank you so much youtube turned pinned messages white
is no way
what's my secret oh wait you didn't tell me that the text
was was black
Oh my god you guys making me look like a damn clown Ducky
thanks for the gifted issues that Zen is in the server so
there's that I think the um the prison thing that that was
really cool I like that hey go thanks for a month thank you
so much sorry I couldn't read people's chats and stuff while
they were happening but thank you very much everybody thanks
for all the gifted thank you for for watching thank you for
donating thank you for um for super chatting thank you thank
you can anyone read it though it'd be cool to know exploring
dungeons with friends is always fun i think also the the the
um the gotcha with the i mean i guess chests are always
gotcha but i also really like that um that each one can be
taken like each person has a different different stuff in
the special chest it's so cool wait a month already hell
yeah doc thank you
the prisoner area is a mod that's based on dead cells along
with the weapons as well okay that's what um yeah yeah
that's what henya was saying earlier too right that I got
Henya and Mouse to help me go around and Mouse was giving oh
my gosh the Dejiko hat I when I saw her wearing it I was
like that looks so much like a Dejiko hat but maybe it's
just a cat hat but it was a Dejiko hat it was so cute and
and then Henya getting the Puchiko hat and this yeah her
cinnamurals so sweet now Mousey helping out was so awesome
oh let me thank you both so much and Ari coming with us it's
so fun oh real question is why do they have dungeons their
basements I know that's just you know standard V show Joe
protocol you know what was I gonna say Fab Achilles thanks
for a month I have to I have to figure out what I'm what I
what my house to be like I think the most the most
intimidating thing is like with all the mods I'm like you
know I'm not used to having so many more more options for
building so I have to get used to it I think hmm so we're
glad to see you going around the V show just server can't
wait to see you meet more new people and have fun on there
thank you make a maid cafe house I was thinking that I I was
thinking that.
There's like a million different blogs.
Oh.
The world is our oyster.
Haunted Made Cafe?
Why do you think I was collecting corpses, huh?
Why do you think I was collecting corpses?
I wonder if there are ghosts in the mod, though.
Like little wisps?
I wonder if there's wisps.
Mmm.
Make Shadow Moses Island.
You know, first of all, Henya making a ride-in reference was
not on my bingo list for tonight.
But also, with the extra blocks and everything, it might
even be possible to make wrecks.
Yeah, there's even RGB blocks.
Pretty sure even one of the builder mods adds over 4,000.
I was in new blocks.
Mid Cafe Rex.
I have to figure out what to build.
And I want to explore.
I feel like maybe a lot of the server has been explored
already, but that's okay too.
With Create, you can make a function Rex, I bet.
Oh my god, that would be...
That would be so insane.
Hmm.
Metal Gear Mid Cafe.
Yeah.
There's still a lot to see.
Okay.
I'm excited.
Claire, thanks for having me.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Minto streaming this late.
Yeah, it is pretty late, huh?
And I streamed late last night, too.
But we're just finishing up.
But I'm actually getting...
I think I have all my social energy.
social energy is just disappeared.
When social energy disappears, my energy disappears.
I also become just a tiny wisp.
It's hard to keep this form.
It's hard to keep this form when I become so sleepy.
But the V-Shojo girls are always in contact with Tofu, so if
you want something added, you could ask oh yes uh the way i
got added to the server was i joined some uh some discord
and actually i was having technical issues with with uh
minecraft just this morning or last night when i was trying
to get in um so i also was like tofu task it day i don't
know tofu but they were very nice ghost tricking your way
through the club not even mouse is exploring the whole
server yet okay leave it to me we'll go on a grand adventure
we'll go on a grand adventure in the server the service
seems so friendly yeah yeah hi mint have you heard that the
metal gear solid board game drops this month if you get it i
wonder if we'll get a hand cam playthrough with matara
that's a great idea i pre-ordered it i pre-ordered it when
they first announced it so
We can see if that can be arranged.
Yeah, thanks for the idea.
Okay.
Does it have spoilers?
No, it's only...
It's only Metal Gear Solid 1.
I believe.
Oh, let me exit out of Minecraft.
I think it's...
Oh.
Hold on, let me...
One second.
We'll take...
We'll go to the maid cafe.
I'm lagging a little bit though.
Recently, my computer has been acting so funky.
Like, uh...
Um...
Oh!
Wait, where are you guys?
What?
Where'd you guys go?
Huh?
We're dead!
There's nothing on the menu.
I missed the last bit of ghost trick, but wanted to mention
after I finished it, I was so floored I had to immediately
drop everything and go buy a sizzle plushie from Etsy.
Thanks again for introducing the game!
Of course!
Glad you liked it as much as I did.
Uh, one second.
Okay, there you are looking bulky.
there we go it's dark um I missed most of the stream but are
you excited to build I am I am I was gonna say oh oh my god
my um recently I was like trying to search for something on
my computer like you know how like when you go to the start
menu when you search for something but like I would go to
search and it stop it would like just the menu would
disappear it was so weird I've been having some weird issues
with my computer lately hopefully hopefully it's okay
mine stream my mine stream minecraft stream are back maybe I
don't want to I don't want to I still am trying to think
about a way to do a membu but I also realized I guess this
sounds kind of mean but if someone stops being a membu if
they still had access to the server, to the Minecraft
server, it wouldn't be very fair so I'm still trying to
figure out how exactly to do it Um, but I also still want,
uh, to not a, not a modern Minecraft, like a vanilla one
too, maybe.
Hmm.
Give us the few Shoto server keys.
Oh yeah, totally.
Make it hardcore for giggles.
Uh, change the password every month.
Oh, mm-mm-mm.
Oh.
I guess that's a good idea.
You can change the password every month.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, that's a smart idea, you guys.
See, I'm glad I brought it up with you guys.
I'm glad I brought it up with you guys.
Let me just DM to me.
She said, Mint, you're in the Minecraft server now.
but yeah it's the username whitelist feature much safer
maybe i don't know there's lots of there's the ways we can
do it i just have to get around to doing it since you love
ghost trick can i recommend a ps2 game ps2 game called
shadow of destiny you you you you you you play as a guy who
uses time travel to stop his own murder.
That sounds so familiar to what we just played.
Let's play together.
Yeah!
Can't wait to play Minecraft, though.
I can't wait to play Minecraft with people, though.
The server seems so active.
I'm so happy.
Oh, I'm so happy.
Seems so active.
Thanks for Minecraft stream.
Thank you, guys!
thank you thank you thank you thank you i am going to go to
sleep now oh my gosh she's inviting me back onto the server
i think i'm gonna go to sleep though um more fun with
friends yeah lotsa minto everybody thank you so much for
watching and hanging out sorry that i wasn't able to
read chat so much but I appreciate you guys hanging out with
me and watching and all the fun stuff so I hope you guys
like the tour as well.
I'll see you guys tomorrow will be I think 3 p.m.
EST still not sure what I'm doing I'll have a waiting room
up tonight but yeah I'll figure it out
okay Otsumita!
Thank you, thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night, and stay hydrated.
And all that fun stuff.
Bye bye!
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye!
See you!